so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody i am thomas
dobaziola whatever you want to call me
this is the dopes usual podcast i'm here
with marty o'neil what's up folks what's
up guys i'm getting right into it all
right i'm excited this is going to be
fun this is going gonna be really fun
and i know you we even talk about this
yet guys it's uh josh and jacob wolf
hello hey everybody hi you know what i
think a couple months ago
i texted you right and i was like hey
man you did let's get [ __ ] up
okay yeah
i do remember that yeah always talking
about the sear
we're talking about what we want and
what we want to do in l.a
in general no yeah
no hold on where's my phone
yeah we were gonna you text me today i
screenshotted this yeah i'm like you
know what it's a good text
it says
josh
11 33 am
how many shrooms are we eating tonight
that's it it's awesome
woke up
and before you went
psychedelic chips we should probably
figure this out
[Laughter]
yeah man i just want to make sure we do
it right but we but i was telling you
earlier you know the most [ __ ] up on
camera i've ever been has always been
with you
because
i know that when i leave the planet
you can keep things together
right a hundred percent and i'll there's
a there's a good chance i'm gonna leave
the planet tonight it's okay yeah yeah i
did i ate mushrooms on the podcast about
a month and a half ago
this sir this man did the ad reads
because i was so gone oh my gosh jesus
which show is that no it's called it's
called mushroom episode oh i might have
to listen to that
were you by yourself it was the two of
you yeah it was just uh were you
shrooming no i was doing a driver
um
all right let's stop because i can't
even do this anymore because i realized
like i'm gonna start talking about stuff
i don't remember he's walking
yeah
that's why that's why this dude is here
hold on
just in case yeah this is your son this
is my son jacob hello everybody
here's my song but he's like yo who is
this man yeah this is
it is weird to have a grown-up as a
child like it's really bizarre for me
because i gotta tell you like sometimes
i'm like i forget how old how old i am i
get it and then this grown-up walks by
me i'm like oh that's my [ __ ] kid
holy [ __ ] dude i understand my little
brother is 17.
he just gradually looks like you
people's tell me all the time
um what you're driving i call me you're
driving oh call me back
oh man you're old now [ __ ]
yeah it's weird right
it has been but now
he and i he's not going to shroom
tonight because he is also the
designated driver dude i am you should
be yeah yeah yeah
i knew it was needed
desperately yeah yeah it is gonna be
desperately needed but i i don't know
have i ever been high on trooms in front
of you
yes you want me to tell you when yeah i
oh oh when you were at my house no can i
tell you when the last time you were
high on mushrooms in front oh oh you're
ready i know okay i also do you know
when oh i know i was there right nope oh
no no no the last recently i can't
remember what we were doing but you were
hanging out with us
and you said
i forgot jake has a baseball game
oh i'm like i'll take you i don't want
you to uber tripping and i remember i
looked look in the rearview mirror
halfway there to look at rosie
i was like
and you're doing this
dude that was the last time i was here
yep i was i was we were filmed an
episode that you i don't know we filmed
a podcast yes and then you're
live that's right that's what happened
and i sat in the stands next to your
girlfriend who i just met first time
first of all
you don't remember what you said no you
did great you did great you actually
didn't spill the beans on me on anything
like you were like i don't want to
embarrass them the first time meeting
you
watch this specials yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it's also a great point like
i was like you know you could just go
like just go on youtube and type in josh
wolfe and you'll know everything yeah
she's like no that's not fun i want the
stories he doesn't tell him i go he
tells every single
yeah what did i what did i say that you
you ready yeah
you
did wait you drove me there yes
you were doing this number
mid-setting son went i'm not gonna
imagine what he was talking about
because he doesn't remember and then
like 40 seconds later you go
i was off the planet for a minute there
man
don't worry man i know
and then we get there and you're like
i'm 15 minutes away
and i can see in your eyes you're like
like when the when the when the dad gets
lost to the beast and beauty and the
beast like oh [ __ ]
there was a forest and you could see him
like oh
i'm like don't worry we're not going to
make you stay out by yourself
i really appreciate you waiting with me
oh my god you pull up and you go
it's the first time i meet his
girlfriend
[ __ ]
and then you get out you left that was
the end of it i know
yeah yo i do remember actually you know
what i remember thinking this is what i
do remember that night i remember
thinking because i i didn't want to be
out at that park in the valley by myself
i remember thinking to myself
thomas is such a good friend for not
leaving me here by myself like
i couldn't do it yo dude
that is right and i was sitting in the
stands trying to keep it together
and watching him play softball
it was difficult it was really really
difficult but i think
i mean i i didn't embarrass myself here
you can go first lucky a [ __ ]
bottle come at you oh
man i don't know why that baseball
field's surrounded with scary arctic i
mean arctic ancient trees dude
it was scary i'm cool thank you it was
real life [ __ ] uh wizard of oz
they're gonna throw apples at me and
[ __ ]
i would never be able to force to get do
you think i was higher that night
or that first night
definitely the first night
yes the first time i met you
that was the first time we had the first
time we met yet but you know what here's
a crazy thing
i'm gonna tell you the truth
from watching you online before you came
i knew i we had never met but i was like
i feel and with marty being there too i
was like
i feel totally comfortable being
incredibly high in front of this dude
like i i was right away i knew i was
like i'm not like this dude a whole
[ __ ] lot yeah and we and that was
also a night you flew the plane for a
little while
for a long
you're so [ __ ] up your wife came
you're good
from the top
he's fine nice to meet you
yeah and that's the night you found out
i don't i don't use water when i swallow
pills yeah i saw that too you're of you
know what he told me the other month
what he walked up to me and goes just i
just thought we started a conversation
hey i think i'm just going to start not
not using any liquid when i swallow
pills for the rest of my life
we randomly talked recently and you said
that about it what the [ __ ] is wrong
with this first of all who the [ __ ]
starts a conversation like that
babe
i'm run dogging those pills
no
no that sounds like people choose to go
vegan
[Laughter]
you know what we're having a water
shortage i'm gonna do my part
i'm not gonna swallow pill i don't know
why i just was decided no more water
with pills
even my wife looks at me like what
is [ __ ] wrong with you
i decided i'm just not gonna chew food
i'm just gonna
just
they should serve that in and out
pelican styles
remember that old house cartoon that
guys eating sandwiches yeah
or liking coneheads yo pelican style
straight
yeah cause you know exactly what we're
talking about by the way pelicans are
dinosaurs
there's they eat
if it was three times as big as it is
now everyone would be like yeah i'm
scared of that that's gonna swallow me
whole that [ __ ] dinosaur i mean
they're still alligators [ __ ]
get eaten all the time by dinosaurs
alligator is a dinosaur a hundred
percent yeah
crocodile that's a anything that hasn't
changed just lived
because
do you know what i mean because they're
like no we're good don't you want to
evolve no i'm pretty feel pretty good in
here you know what i mean
we were in the water [ __ ]
no we're doing the same [ __ ] you know
what i mean yeah yeah those dudes and
sharks i don't think have changed too
much
do you so you guys like the water do you
get in the ocean no i do not i do you're
scared i don't know
don't get in the water no i don't surf
but i definitely get in there i won't
[ __ ] with the water in the water
anything i can't see through
with it that's it that's getting lakes
i'm cool dude
on lakes in certain areas when like in
areas where you know there's not gonna
be a crocodile there's no no
murky water out yo if i can't see my
feet i see a creep show yeah and i know
things pop out the [ __ ] water
yeah
i did a show on discovery called it was
shark after dark during shark week right
what it means and it was it was an aft
after they did all the shark shows it
was a late night
talk show
based around sharks
so
awesome they
they were like do you want to swim with
sharks in real life
did you say yeah i feel like you did
[Music]
so
i never
i i don't swim well i've never been in a
scuba suit i've never had flippers on
before
i've never snorkeled
i also get these things called um
cluster headaches you know what those
are dude that's what i started getting
last year they suck dick oh dude cluster
headaches are and and there isn't like a
pain medication that works
i got the needle how did it do the guy
didn't tell me he was gonna stick it in
my [ __ ] head
he's all what about this man i really
don't like neat i went ah
i feel better all right [ __ ] you yeah
wait
needle in the head oh [ __ ] you a needle
in the head to the temple to the temple
that seems if it's wrong
it's dangerous
let me ask you something right now what
what at the top of your head seems like
it might hurt more
needle
bottom of the foot
oh needle underarm oh under armour
i go under arm too i think
they at least flex it out a little bit
your foot you're just you're just
vulnerable man that bottom of the foot i
watched your sister take a huge needle
to the bottom of the foot i was there
she she was there she got a big piece of
wood stuck in her foot what does that
have to do with it well they needed to
take it out why they stick a needle in
there like that to numb it
hey it was that numbing shot and then
tweezed it out yeah that was
i had to help hold her down how old was
she
she's feisty yeah she
she was seven
no no you were oh
so if you were around seven so she must
be around ten
something like that yeah yeah you don't
like needles i i've had a lot i have a
lot of stories
about needles i used to walk into the
office and they would be like thomas is
here
because they know
like i said i used to be i mean i'm
strong i used to be a [ __ ] freaking
ancient when i was like 10
i could dead lift like 200 pounds as a
kid don't know what my dad used to make
me lift weights when i was a kid he was
[ __ ] dumb
anyway the first time they tried to give
me a shot i threw this [ __ ] doctor to
the ground no and he looked at me like
what the [ __ ] was that and my mom's
apologizing he brings a nurse in and
like do you think she's gonna get off
two nurses the doctor nothing they had a
janitor come sit on my hips and hold me
up my ass down
i once got stuck in the in the window
when the doctor went to get the needle
because i tried to scape out the [ __ ]
the window that's hilarious got stuck
and then put the needle mark stuck in
the window i would have stuck it right
in your ch oh he he got me
my mom help my mom's a dick [ __ ] you
you know you're watching too i don't
like needles sorry
joe diaz used to pass out
really yeah i almost passed out last
year he would he used to pass out i
think it's getting better since he had
his daughter but since he has already
had to toughen the [ __ ]
let me tell you something for real there
are a bunch of things that i was scared
of and as soon as i had kids i was like
i can't be scared of these anymore
because i
i can't pass it down that and you can't
be like
oh i can't i can't see i can't have them
seeing me react like that now i will say
i do scare easily
and i do jazz hand
oh dude
if you get them it's a it's a jazz it's
it's yeah it's a jazz hand and it's this
it's this noise ah like it is like
embarrassing i can see that oh that's
too bad
i mean you just did it
i did it yeah
it comes from like i grew up with three
older brothers
so i was scared
all the time
yeah and they were always hiding behind
things and so like i didn't always jazz
hand but they kind of beat it into me do
you know my oldest brother used to like
to scare me because i'd go ah right like
this but then he found that when he
punched me in the chest i made this
noise
so
if he scared me and then punched me the
chest i made this noise
and he was like you sound like a donkey
so he would scare me and punch me
because it made him laugh the noise made
him that's that is pretty funny it is
pretty funny
i'm not gonna lie human soundboard the
human soundboard let's go beat the [ __ ]
out of our little brother
there's no video games yet
that's probably what it was
i remember one time
my brother pulled a knife on my other
brother
and my friend was over
and my my brother picked my friend up
and put him in front of him and was like
i think you might have told me did i
tell you that yeah i think so that
sounds so familiar i could be wrong
yeah i could be wrong human shield i
think you and the human shield yeah he
human shielded him i think we did talk
about this
oh yeah it's not great oh question yeah
have you ever had to beat the [ __ ] out
of him as a child no
no no i always thought like i can't see
josh going go to your [ __ ] room and
smack in the [ __ ] no no no i can't see
that it's not wasn't my style yeah and
by the way
i i look it wasn't my style
i didn't have a kid who i ever thought
i'm just gonna need to beat the show
yeah do you know what i mean like i mean
i don't but i get it like like
like i for me it didn't suit my style or
my kids did any of your kids really test
you over and over and over and over
again though yeah
can you give me some advice
yes
yes
yes but i thought here can i tell you
honestly what i thought
i felt like
part of the problem we were having was
trust and i felt like if i was
physically violent
that that would not help the trust
that somebody who hits me i don't trust
i can't
i'm scared of that person i can't it's
hard for me to trust that person so
it was a specific issue
and um
for me i was like this is not going to
be productive
i i need to
show to show this little person that no
matter how many times they test me
i'm i'm here no did you blast any
teenage boys along the way having a
daughter
that's a real [ __ ] issue hold on i
don't know punch let's say punch no i
never know
okay
listen streets are real out here the
streets are real out here josh is
murking [ __ ] teenagers
the [ __ ] the the crime rate dropped
in tennessee
when he left
it's always rising in vegas but that's
why he's in vegas
that don't make sense
not the the only the only person i ever
had to talk to
was his 21 year old dude
who was
hanging around with my daughter when she
was 18 but she was still in high school
and my my issue was and he was like
she's 18 i'm like and in high school
so when she leaves high school
you guys i can't stop you from talking
but she lives in my house
and at my house these are these rules
and my teenager who's in high school
doesn't date 21 year olds
that's weird i i for you that's it as a
20 because you're a guy and you're 21
and you're like i can't go to high
school to pick up my girlfriend pick my
girl from high school man
this is pedophile shh
i feel awkward sorry for everyone out
there in the same situation
two dudes just looked at it as their
friend
mark
he's talking right to me
speaking of my soul
this is the moment
so hold on
have you
ever had to beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody because of him
now that's a question i want to hear i'm
at school but i don't like your dad's
comedy you want me to beat the [ __ ] out
of here
i'm just kidding no there was never a
situation where like
i had to do anything for people i just
was told to
shrug it off and i learned that from an
early age because there were jokes about
me but also you know it it didn't matter
what they thought oh when did you find
out that these jokes are about you
oh i could tell you
i would i was in on it early yeah i
would run it by here's the deal i would
run it by him i'd be like what do you
think about me telling the story and
he'd say i don't want you to tell it i'd
be like okay let me check back in with
you about six months and so there that
the dick pic story
he did not want me telling that story uh
that fresh j's came from boys
[Music]
you know what he did say dude that might
be one of the funniest [ __ ] things
though he was talking to me he was like
about hey can i borrow some money
and i was giving him this whole lecture
about being responsible
and all this stuff and he was like let
me ask you he said aren't most your
jokes about me i go yeah he goes so i'm
the indirect breadwinner of this family
i was like god damn yeah
that's not true
i'm not wrong you're a writer
you're a writer that's what i'm saying
you're a reality right
yeah you're a [ __ ] showrunner
so before i get [ __ ] up and forget
and we we keep going into random
tangents please tell me about your
guys's show oh because that is [ __ ]
awesome that you guys are doing it
together that's pretty funny we do a
podcast called hey man
and how many a's
and uh it's really look there's
some of my favorite stuff
is you know he admits things to me that
i didn't know
yo he admitted
he was like remember like he was like
you know i walked in on you and mama
it's like oh what i go how old was he at
i thought you thinking he's going to say
like seven or eight he was like 17. i
was like oh no
yeah
that's so different
that's so different
so different
yeah terrifying but i didn't need to
hear it on a [ __ ] live stream do you
know what i'm saying i don't know he
told me yeah yeah she decided to drop it
well you know what she's learning from
yeah yeah i do
100
and so he talks to me a lot about you
know uh stories that i know um
we have a lot of so i get a lot there's
a lot of me i tell stories about him
also
a lot of people like that [ __ ] um but
what i really like is like
look man we come from completely
different generations so my scope on
what good hip hop is and what his on
what good hip hop is or mine on who the
greatest basketball player is and him
thinking it's lebron james which is
[ __ ] bananas lebron and where are you
going michael george okay
and so like but like it there's
there is something for everybody because
we tell a lot of family stories that are
embarrassing and funny
but also look there are people who are
closer to my age who are going to agree
with me and there are people who are
closer to him his age who are wrong
[Laughter]
they'll understand one day yeah yeah
right dude it [ __ ] went through my
brain and came back what the [ __ ] did
you just
i'm really high
i didn't really smoke that much but
it's fun man and he's funny we have a
good time yeah he's funny he is funny
he's funny he's
and he's quick and
he can insult me in a way
because he knows things about me that
that nobody else can and he does little
things like one of my favorite things to
do is just to do tiny things to bother
people
just repeatedly it's the worst i mean
one of us is the [ __ ] worst like
for i just i
you know he's going to coachella right
and he hates the fact that i call it
coachella
uh-huh why
and because he thinks how do you say it
how do you say it coachella how do you
say it coachella
so he hates it right similar that's the
subtle thing that'll drive your [ __ ]
channel drives him it drives him
absolutely nuts
he only says he only says coachella he
doesn't say coachella every time he sees
me he makes sure he says it every time
we're on the phone he's like because it
hasn't come up yet so every time we talk
he's like you excited for coachella and
i'm like
yeah i love yeah i'm super excited so i
love doing those little things to bother
people but he is the only person who
knows my [ __ ] and will do it to me so he
does that [ __ ] to me in the podcast it's
a lot of fun man that's one
give me one and the repeat thing yeah
it's just you know repeating what he
says
he repeats a killer a question
like i didn't like he didn't hear me
like i'll be like hey
hey dude is your is your smoke out
yeah
is it out yeah you know he's asking you
the actual question it is it out what do
you mean is it out
he's saying are you going to repeat it
he's trying to give an example so i just
asked you that like four times hold on i
just asked you that four times oh that's
what the example that's what i do and i
just bother him no that honestly didn't
even bother me i thought i was so high i
wasn't even answering the questions
right
og it's so like so so doesn't it
unintentionally so like we
but we know that [ __ ] about each other
and and so it's just a good time man it
really is this
josh is such a good actor
he got me
i practice being an ass
highly trained in the arts hey
yeah
yeah whatever you guys on what uh 18
what do you think about it i mean i love
it
it's just you know it's a fun it's a fun
spot for us to just be able to get our
tell our story and tell it in different
ways because you know there are some
episodes where we do just [ __ ] around
with each other and it's it's a fun
episode
uh the one we filmed today was just
weird like random like there was no
topics we just jumped in on one thing
and just let it ride for like 40 minutes
today's the first time i'm trying that
yeah because i know you guys pretty well
like i don't need no notes that's just a
talk yeah yeah but that's what that's
what people who like each other do yeah
it's pretty awesome
that's what people who like each other
do and so that's why i think this is
it's also fun to listen to because
obviously we genuinely like each other
yeah i would hope so and can i tell you
mo and secretly
he's never heard me say this
but at his age
to have this amount of bonus time with
your kid is like
i can't it's
my favorite thing all week yeah i i can
see why you know what i mean yeah
it's definitely fun it's definitely a
good time and i mean it's cool that
you're like oh my god my dad but you
know it's not what you're thinking yeah
right it's different exactly yeah
[Laughter]
so you're on episode 18. on episode 18
what is it there what what is it like a
scheduled every
well it will be now that he's back from
panama so you're in panama real quick
yeah doing the netflix show yeah i was
in panama doing a netflix show which was
pretty dope i mean did you bump panama
while you were there
i've never been on the plane like that's
what i would have done that's that kid i
[ __ ]
i mean
i don't know anything about
was it it was
i mean it was great i mean it was there
for six weeks and it was it was a
[ __ ] week six weeks so it was it was
great for the first three weeks and then
i was like all right i'm i'm ready to go
back
a lot of banana leaves stuff yeah never
seen some
crazy things like there were some
insects i thought i'd never seen in
person there were some
yeah there were some monkeys there was
we were pretty much in
an isolated part of a peninsula where
there were two resorts and then the rest
of it was just uninhabited jungle
and you had to like there was like a
restaurant like 15 minutes down the
street but other than that to get into
the city it was like a 30 minute drive
and so it was just like we were not
remote
that's [ __ ] i would call that the
definition yeah but we were we were we
were pretty much
remote i know did you like the show
i mean i had fun okay that's all that
matters i mean i was there for school i
was working 60-hour weeks and so i was
invested in the show that we were
filming and i was like that's fun man
sure this is fun yeah i'm excited to see
how it turns out dude at your age to be
able to go to panama
work 25.
come on man it was it was dope it was
definitely experience yeah i mean i
would definitely go back for a vacation
dude
if you think about
at your age what you've already been
able to do you know over quarantine when
everybody else was locked down
this dude was doing a reality show for
amazon
in the national forest so he was just
outside and this be everybody else was
stuck inside
was in zion and all these beautiful
[ __ ] places right and so
you you've had some
wow yeah how did you get into that how
did you get into a netflix working on
shows um i think my first foot in the
door was uh
obviously and so the first show i mean
i've technically ever worked on was the
josh wolf show the summer of 2015. and
that was like they're like yeah we'll
just put you on the payroll
you were pa you did a little bit
everything yeah you were on at least one
show a week weren't you i was there five
days a week i came in with you no you
were on youtube
oh oh oh oh like on the show i drove in
with yeah yeah yeah
no no you brought me to the gym at 6 00
a.m every year them go to jimmy
but but you uh
you were aren't you on about yeah i was
on i was on the last episode which was
dope i was on the panel like i was like
one of the three seats so that was
super cool that was awesome
you also made me dress up for fourth of
july as uncle sam and do three
cartwheels on stage mom i could see that
yeah i didn't walk off no it was fun you
did catch a paintball to the mouth
uh a paint balloon sir
oh that's different
he actually hold on not only did he
throw it at me let me just
[Music]
wait
let me clarify he not only threw it at
me he strapped me to a board and threw
multiple at me oh you signed up for this
i thought you were like walking got
popped out
i did not see you no i know we ran it by
him first yeah
i got signed up to stand there not get
strapped well i thought i thought you'd
try to move out of the way
i was throwing him right
and um i threw one as he was opening his
mouth
and it always
a large one a balloon went right into
his mouth and i have it on slow motion i
think i have it on my phone yeah i
actually sent it to maria's i know
see it go in and then you slow motion
see ya
cause i just spit it out
we were both dressed up in old old-time
baseball it's beautiful and i had on
i've seen this picture and i and i had a
catcher's helmet on or a mask on and so
when he threw it it hit me right in the
center of the mask as i said something
right here yeah and it hit
right in the mouth and it and he just i
i spit it out and he walked up and he
was like you okay and i spit out again
and i was like we're done yeah we're
done we're done this is the last balloon
yeah we're done right boy that's that
man you never want to have to say that
that was the last balloon we're done
yeah that could be
you know it's a popular dude that could
mean a lot of things
yeah yeah yeah bits are mad popular
you know what when i was in philadelphia
have i told you the story that they they
had this nitrous mafia it was a failure
what is that that was detroit
now philly so they would
and i may be a little high but i think
it's called the philly nitrous mafia and
they have tanks and they wait outside of
concerts
they do that they do that here heavy and
so backpacks so and so like we were
walking outside of the
comedy club
and they were just a wall of [ __ ]
zombies
just and so you know when the cops come
they open the tank and they kick it down
the street
and so by the time the cops get there
it's empty
so they can't so it's like
a beer bottle yeah yeah i wasn't
drinking it's so it's crazy but um
man they when they knock they were at
the end of this long alley type street
and they just kind of knocked the cans
together the canisters
and they just get the zombies just kind
of hugging how [ __ ] disgusting
walking dead it over to them you clink
bottles to like dogs when you [ __ ]
dinner bells
yeah that's what it is oh god you know
question
i don't think we've ever talked about
this did you ever [ __ ] with different
drugs when you were younger as a kid
um i [ __ ] around with ecstasy okay i
like the
uh i like you're like a mother pta yeah
that's how you look do your hand on it
um i i am not
i never liked coke
i mean i and i tried it i gave it a shot
i gave it a shot i did i gave it i gave
it a religion i mean i tried
i gave it its fair shake not for me you
know what it made me do it made me
sit in the corner and shut up
oh it did the opposite effect it had the
complete opposite effect on me yeah
that's not your personality i i just fun
for him no and i tried meth once by
accident oh tell me tell me tell me how
cause i got a mess door too
well i'm putting this on the table yeah
it's too [ __ ] much sorry guys
there we go better
this dude bought what he thought was
coke
was it your uncle
no
exactly
sorry keep going you know what happened
that's exactly what happened he thought
he bought coke and it was [ __ ] god
well it was crack it was crack but it
this was meth i've never done crack not
funny let me tell you neither is meth it
was
uncomfortable it's the only so we were
so you know that
film of sweat you get over your
body but mostly your gross face it's the
hard drug sweat yeah i know that a
feeling it is not attractive
and so it's the only time i was i was
holding a ginatonic
it's the only time ever at a strip club
that a strip when i asked a stripper for
a dance she was like no
oh you know you're doing bad
she was like nah no yeah nah just like
it was it was real dismissive she looked
that you went you're on one yeah
and i was like
my job was probably like oh i wonder
what's wrong with it look at like fire
marshall yeah exactly
i wonder why she said no i don't
understand yeah if i can join it up oh
man i accidentally smoked meth i was 14
with this [ __ ] girl i thought i was
smoking weed and there was meth on it
and it [ __ ] ruined my whole night
[Music]
i just i was drinking
did you say gin
i was drinking gin
first time i ever tried gin i was
[ __ ] 14.
and i just started projectile throwing
it up because i was spinning but i was
on one i didn't like the feeling yeah
meth is disgusting yeah don't do math no
yeah don't do it you get shorter so
ecstasy you losing mushrooms ecstasy
mushrooms acid weed i'd love to try dmt
maybe
it's i'm not ready for the commitment
yet i'm not really no i don't think i'm
like
how much time do i have to recover but
you but they say it's zero recovery no
i'm gonna be dwelling on [ __ ] for about
a day and a half like oh god i already
know yeah maybe no physical recovery
have you ever done a recovery no [ __ ] no
i just barely did mushrooms the other
day
you haven't been here marty [ __ ] took
mushrooms finally
come on man
we've been over it in great detail how
many grams did you take
that's up for debate
it was like a half a chocolate bar which
is four of those [ __ ] supplement
pills because the chocolate bar didn't
do dicks so then i was like no it did no
it definitely yeah
yeah yeah yeah so what we're talking
like maybe three and a half already
eight like maybe four grams maybe a
little more socks your first jump in
that's a full no he i gave him three
grams the day before because they hadn't
it didn't do [ __ ] to him and then what
yeah me and april didn't together april
started tripping off the [ __ ] two or
three of the little pills and then i was
sitting there i got frustrated or off
the half a chocolate buyer then i i had
some of the pills left and then it
[ __ ] kicked in and it was amazing
it's pretty great yeah it was pretty fun
it's pretty great i was chilling like
there was no bad there was nothing weird
about it it was just very visual and i
was just like bursting out laughter yeah
yeah you know that's by the way
that's like any time anybody says
anything negative about mushrooms i'm
like you've never done
you've never ever tried are you telling
me that the funnest thing in the world
is not fun is that what you're trying to
tell me yeah that the best thing is not
the best thing is that what you're
trying to say to me right now that seems
a little weird
because you'll always get here's when
you know somebody's never done mushrooms
yeah i had one real bad trip no you went
one yeah the first time you quit at one
that's crazy yeah
yeah drink a beer it tastes funny yeah
it's also like
do you know like when you do it
sometimes do you ever do do you ever do
them for different reasons like
sometimes i'll do it like where i'm like
i want to solve a problem
and oh oh dude you're different our last
guest was a [ __ ] expert was an expert
in phil simon essentially really he
explained some
crazy ways of taking shrooms
just so does did what i just say make
any sense it's what he does he's i have
different intentions for different
things that's what i've been doing it's
called the lemon attack the lemon juice
lines the mushes that mushrooms down an
eighth yeah and squeezes lemon juice on
it and lets it mix
because the acidity is like our stomach
so it starts to break down so when you
drink it it hits you fast it's [ __ ]
sick
because it's like you ate them
doing that
isn't that
interesting i'm doing that next i mean i
put it i put it in green it's got to be
[ __ ] better how do you like how do
you like mushrooms i like mushrooms a
lot yeah i never never had i like
mushrooms a lot i think mushrooms are
great i've done acid before as well i
never said those are the only two things
i've i've done some
i've done some i did some a lot of asset
a weekend he was out of town i told you
the story i think at my house yeah at
the house what age were you uh
17 18. somewhere in there that sounds
cool and uh
i was up for
52 hours
long straight
by the way that sounds terrible in a
horrible way or in a cool way oh it was
amazing oh bomb
yeah yeah
it was great it was great it's awesome i
had a good time that's a tweaker
psychedelic time though 52 hours to be
tweaked or be tripping yeah that was the
last time i did acid because it was just
like yo that was cool and all but like i
don't really want to also commit 12
hours of my life just to one
thing that's the thing the last time i
took acid i remember thinking
i wish this was over now
a bunch of times i hate that dude yeah
when i know i'm having fun and then you
know when mushrooms you'll be having the
greatest time then like what's this
bipolar switch i wish i was off
out of nowhere yeah that's a bummer when
that comes it happened to me i did
mushrooms in the for the first time in
in in uh the day
like a month ago
i really do in the day i always do them
in the dark in my pitch black room and
trip the [ __ ] out
day's kind of fun man oh it was [ __ ]
good
i liked it
great you know what you know it's great
sunshine i was outside at the at the uh
batting cages and the mini golf
castle park is that what it's called
it's over on sherman oaks
yeah it's gym notes yeah
okay yeah that's where it was i used to
take him there yeah that's where i went
that's where i went
[Laughter]
and then i didn't drive
and i went to the sandwich spot and then
didn't like it no i've never had like a
bad trip it wasn't a bad trip it was
just like a
i don't like any i want you i want all
these strangers away from me my friends
were cool when i was in the public like
oh trees i can hear the trees i have to
tell you
if i'm public and i'm tripping
i have to be
outdoors outdoors
outdoors gotcha not in the cities nah
joshua tree
a backyard with a lot of space
with some peop not that many people
other people who are high
i would i love to be able to look at the
sky basically i loved it i just tried
like i said first time of the day wow
yo you should go out have you gone out
to joshua tree i've never been there oh
yeah
i've never been there i'm uh see this is
people always say why don't you go do
[ __ ] to my friends travel go do this and
like
ready
i was poor
and then i sold drugs i don't travel you
don't travel you sell drugs you have to
sell drugs
and then i stop selling drugs i've been
doing this
that's why i haven't done anything
that's it yeah that's my whole life up
to today
that's so crazy dude i've never done
[ __ ]
oh you should do a little something yeah
i have a schedule now so i can actually
like plan things what's something you
want to do crushing it now
what's something you want to do
i have no idea i've never thought about
it
that's so crazy but what's your hobby
like [ __ ] nothing
i have no hobbies all right let's spit
ball a couple places watch the sidewalk
seinfeld do you want to do i mean that's
a good house yeah all right are you
would you would you rather go to europe
or south america europe i want to try
europe okay hht just got legalized in
london so i want to do a pop-up there
for our brand oh [ __ ]
scotland
by the way
great now it's a business write-off
yeah yeah right i would go to london i
would go to london right
i would go to europe i just
i really hate flying
and i hate the water and you got to do
both to get there
it's so exciting yeah
how do you feel about xanax i don't like
any pills
i will [ __ ] myself up on the plane
that's fine oh yeah i'll eat the most
stars so i've ever eaten in my life
yeah but it scares me like
i i just have the fear of flying and
open water
i hate them both like we talked about
earlier dude [ __ ] that open water
[ __ ]
were we on the podcast alligators or
dinosaurs that was tonight that was
tonight yeah that was that's not good
for my head yeah dude that was just a
few minutes ago probably
[Laughter]
it was it was huh uh wait what time are
we at 45 oh man it was less than an hour
ago [ __ ]
it's okay it's uh
where's the mushrooms at are you gonna
eat any
oh i don't have any oh my god i had him
at my house
i thought you oh my god hold on
let's go
catch rosie real quick like yo can you
bring all those mushrooms on the table
yo if this was like 200 years ago we
would have to [ __ ] write a letter
you also should have told me i didn't
know i didn't know i didn't know that's
100
that's my fault that's my fault
can you bring
those
mushroom cats
they are on your desk
i'm over here talking we're on we're
literally people on spotify listening to
me my text my bad guys
and i didn't bring my bag
it's okay what do you need
the mushrooms okay we got we got them
they're strong the caps are very strong
so i would suggest we just eat like two
or three and then we'll see how you feel
and do some more but you might believe
six yeah listen i'm gonna i'm gonna
stick around with you guys
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do what you do
all right yeah because
maybe i won't i'm not real good at that
i don't think you will
he's gonna see pills and swallow the
bottle before much
it's gonna happen
but these are the ones i ate uh when i
went outside
uh when i ate them uh in the day these
are the same uh they're supposed to be
micro
uh
micro doses but when you eat eight of
them it's not it turns into a just a
regular yeah
it's a macro dose yeah that's exactly
what happened to me yeah but you know
what like
you can always get more that's mine
i'm like why that's a good attitude you
know what i mean
what the [ __ ] what was it happening
my father's in prison for four years for
some weed oh that must have been the
[ __ ]
is that you
i could pull 60. like that's funny
so hold on
what's your perspective of this of
because you know when you're i mean not
you [ __ ]
you know when you were a kid or you were
a kid and you you see
let's just say like damn that's adam
sandler's kids how weird is it that your
dad's just like a funny ass fool people
love that dude
so hey how do you feel about that that
must be odd my dad's cool but he's a
truck driver
i mean he's chilling i mean i don't know
it's just always what i've grown up
knowing i guess you know do you know
what i'm saying i get it so
16. it's different than when you were
seven
yeah okay and you're like
my [ __ ] dad's talking about oh that's
me that's my dick pig [ __ ]
like when did it turn into like you
there must have been a time
where you looked at like wow
[ __ ] dad's this is tight there had to
have been that moment where you're like
this is different from when i was a kid
and i know my dad makes people laugh now
i'm laughing because i get the jokes um
yeah i would i would probably say around
18 18 or 19 right yeah it was uh we
we had met uh someone who was like uh an
athlete that i look up to a lot
and i had met him for the first time and
he walked up to me shook my hand gave me
a hug and
first thing he brought up was the icloud
joke which is the dick pic joke
and and he said it's my favorite joke it
makes me laugh every time
and uh it's great to meet you and i was
like cool and then we ended up and
going and grabbing dinner and he just
was just treating me like a
regular person even after that some
people take it a little far but like it
was just
a moment it was like one of those core
memories right yeah i'll get you and so
after that i was like yo you can tell
whatever jokes you want like i'm out of
it we're good i'm out of it you know it
just happened i'm i'm good yeah i was
like i was like i'm good like i am i am
good so
do what you need to but it also like
inadvertently maybe
but it has taught him a great lesson
which is
who gives a [ __ ]
yeah
exactly he gives a [ __ ]
who gives the [ __ ] what you think who
gives a [ __ ]
it's such a good lesson to learn early
i wish i learned you're younger do you
know what i mean to be able to be like
you know all that is really not real and
who gives a [ __ ] oh do you know what i
mean what a bumper sticker who gives a
[ __ ] yeah i love that it goes for
anything but for but like
and i i would love to take
credit for
that being the reason that i posted the
videos it wasn't it definitely wasn't no
i i know that and everybody else knows
that
but you know what man we've had a good
time he's been coming on the road with
me
and i'm coming on stage with me some
it's been a lot of fun
we watched your special we watched the
special well no you weren't in that one
no no i was that one i introduced
me in the first one
uh the second one was uh it was in
tennessee yeah it was yesterday
that wasn't it national yeah
but like
yeah he comes on stage and people ask us
questions
ask him what it was like being raised by
me they asked him embarrassing questions
about me
which he has some pretty good ones
they asked some stories they asked just
questions about the stories that he
tells yeah man it's a good time when he
comes on stage it's a good time it's
like
getting the bts of your favorite [ __ ]
yeah
with the person that you're like yo so
this is the best that's it yeah that's
it
long hair
exactly hey he's he's tall yeah i know
he's why is he taller than you yeah
that's the favorite that's his favorite
one
um but like we have we have a good we
have a good time on there yeah for
[ __ ] sure absolutely the first time i
ever heard your name
marty text me
it's like a comedian i work with
he texts me
and i'm like okay cool name
that's what i thought i went to the
comedy store with my uncle john actually
and my aunt pepper
and you walked on stage i heard the name
what
that's the [ __ ] marty was
talking about stuff
he's
and i was behind you and you're telling
the story about you smoked a joint and
drove up a road and thought you were
going to get pulled over or crashed or
something [ __ ] insane and they were
thinking
ah that's the kind of comedy i want to
get
and then i won't say his name
but
it was the reaction
it was the reaction
you like stunned yourself
that's like a gta when hit the wall
yeah i remember thinking this is the
kind of [ __ ] i want to see and we won't
say but another comedian came up and
ruined the whole night and then the rest
of the night happened but you opened i
know you were like a third person up and
i just remember thinking
all right i'm already working with funny
guy yeah i appreciate that yeah i think
[ __ ] is funny
all right cool i was like hey
good night it was a good [ __ ]
it's always fun there those lineups are
showing outside i made my day yeah like
i spoke to jordan outside and walked
into the store or into the comedy show
it was [ __ ] fun i i i
it's
such a cool place to be on any given
night because the lineups are always a
plus
to be fair pretty much everywhere and
you know the
improv and the life factory
they all get good lineups too but
the store seems to stop i think it's
something different i think that one's
always like
yeah
but you're not going to go wrong really
it's always going to be fun yeah at any
three of those clubs because there's a
lot of great
comics living in los angeles right now
yeah 100
there's so
[ __ ] many
like
here's the thing the reason so many
people are getting into comedy
is because the people who are the best
at it
make it look so easy oh that's a good
way to put it right so you're like i can
[ __ ]
bill birdle he leans on this
ay he leans on this yes leans on this
stand like he's just kind of like what's
going on
i'm just going to i just got a couple
things i'm just going to run by you
but this is on my list
do you know what i mean but like it took
20 years of that but that's what i'm
saying but but the the
there's so many people doing it at such
a high level
it looks easy
i get that so like right now for me
look there's been a lot of times with
great comics but right now for me
i mean the depth of how many good comics
there are
there's no way there's another time
oh i totally agree with you right now
there's no
you can just type a name in youtube and
you can be 24 hour just going on the
funniest [ __ ] you ever saw people you
haven't even heard most of the time like
who is this person
[ __ ] hilarious that's the
i love that [ __ ]
it's crazy right now if there's a lot of
funny [ __ ] out there absolutely
[ __ ] many and the best part about it
is right now
there's a little bit of everything
that you if you are like i don't like
comedy you're not looking hard enough
there's something in somebody out there
there are p and people like i know there
are a lot of people who are like it's
too pc
there are some very dark
oh those are my comics out there right
now everybody people that make it 100 oh
[ __ ] yeah are my favorites yeah yeah the
people who make you laugh uncomfortably
at uncomfortable things that's what the
point of it is that's
that those are like the
yeah i think that's the point
yeah so the there
i was saying this to you earlier for me
joey diaz is that guy
i think he's everyone's favorite vulgar
as [ __ ] human
comedian and not storytelling that full
is funny yo dude for for 15 minutes
there's
in that o.r at the comedy store
i've never seen anyone do to that room
there's a lot i mean and and they're
dude not putting anybody down
but for me if you were like who's the
the [ __ ]
most raucous you've ever seen that room
for 15 minutes it'd be joe diaz just
when he's
firing on all
pistons
it's [ __ ]
on yo i talked to him i was telling him
i talked to him on the phone last night
i my stomach hurt
i was drooling you know when you're
laughing so hard you drew yeah i always
feel so stupid
yeah right it's coming out
but it's like
but it reminds me i'm having a good time
if i'm drooling and i don't know
like
doing a lot of stand-up in new york no
she's not none oh [ __ ] i mean maybe he's
pop he might be popping on stage but
i don't think he's i never heard of him
before like four years ago
and i went to the comedy store and they
introduced this guy went
i know that is that that mother
was he in basketball i'm like what if i
didn't know this guy he wasn't basically
i watched it a lot like i know that face
and then he talked about tucking stuff
in his dick skin and i went yo this is
the funniest [ __ ] i might have
ever seen in my life and he just kept
going
i wasn't ready for that kind i didn't
know
people just go hard like i mean there's
but you you know there's vulgar comments
that's different level yeah but but but
but you know
here's and this is a tip of the hat to
joe
and why he's so good
is
very few people
are offended
he's so authentic it's hard to be
offended that's just them
by him he's so authentic
that like if somebody else was saying it
you might be some people might be like
what the [ __ ] dave chappelle has that
quality too right so like but
joey is so authentic there's no
him being him on stage
so like i mean you guys know best
if that's the same [ __ ] on and
off stage dude this dude he
joey babysat him oh uncle joey
babysitter i mean we have a clip of that
yeah from what time we talked about
yeah
so like i've known this dude for a long
time
yeah
but he's always made me laugh i mean
like uncontrollably
so
would you say as a comic who is your
favorite comic
unbiasedly saying joey diaz you mean for
in forever okay go forever
jimin like my favorite of all time
favorite of all time hold on as a kid
and then as a comic
i just asked the rapper who's your
favorite rapper right now
here we go go go for it as a kid it was
um sam
and what are we defining kid
probably can't like candace is the first
one who really got my
attention
i
i
i had watched other people
like i remember the first
comedy album
or special that really made me i was
just like what my dad let me stay up and
watch um
carlin live at carnegie hall
and different level
on hbo just i think it was hbo i was
pretty young
but
i remember just like
my dad commented me at to me after i i
didn't think you'd like that so much
really yeah how old were you though i
don't remember
honestly i don't remember how old i was
i was pretty um
feels like 10 11 12 something like that
okay
ballpark
ballpark
you just cut somebody off face
but um as a comic now
that's so hard to say
i know i needed to hear it though i
banned the mic to the head he's thinking
there's so i
oh wow that was me man
i went do i hear my own you [ __ ] by
the way you know what i thought i was
like am i having a stroke right now oh
my god
i was like is that me
[ __ ] that the first one first heartbeat
i was like i was like what second one i
was like oh wait no wait hold on sound
boy
i forg i just thought automatic like is
this the time yeah is this again is this
it was the week i was like i was like
can everybody hear this that's exciting
yo if you had said that i might have
[ __ ] myself laughing
there's mushrooms in this hey uh oh yeah
what's up with that delivery mushroom my
favorite
i i
sorry i'm trying to try to be rude i'm
just i'm ordering mushrooms to this
place sorry guys
i
i don't know oh okay could you give your
favorite [ __ ] curry let me say this
let me say this three i can say the
person who makes me laugh the hardest
outside of joey diaz
is
probably cat williams oh great i love
that
sir that [ __ ] is the ultimate
roaster of all time i love that
so [ __ ] so funny you know
does he make you go how did you do it
that fast
how did you come up with that so fast
you [ __ ]
yeah i mean
hard
you like loud ass fools sam kinnison
[ __ ] cat william
cat williams
makes me laugh now
i want to you're saying alive today
because if not i got to change my answer
go any oh patrice o'neill hands oh bro
good [ __ ] hands down hands down hands
you look like a fish
[Laughter]
i'm not going to say that he was the
best but who made me laugh who makes me
laugh
like nobody else is so funny dude
can i harass you a little bit too just a
little bit let me sexually harass you
sometimes
i'm gonna go watch this [ __ ] tonight
this [ __ ] pink guy thank you my when
to not mention him
would be a disservice like as i'm not
saying he's the best comic ever but you
asked me who who makes me laugh the
hardest
that dude and by the way
somebody put up
a 33 or 34 minute clip
of his what they called his funniest
which i don't think it was his funniest
tribute i'm sorry but it's just clip
after clip after clip from different
special from different yo it it's almost
scary to be in that front row super
funny
super funny but but for me it's it's
it's
it's gotta be patrice wow great [ __ ]
answer
good [ __ ] you like patrice a lot yeah
yeah a lot youtube is just for fights
ignorant [ __ ]
stand ups yo patrice o'neill and
watching norm mcdonald ruin interviews
that's my i love watching that i've
never seen that watch tonight
compilation nor mcdonald ruining
interviews he will straight up say the
worst [ __ ]
and not give a [ __ ]
on live tv doesn't matter where he's at
this [ __ ]
yo i love this stuff yeah i watch that
often so i'm gonna watch i'm gonna watch
uh okay some [ __ ] tonight now
i might watch patrice again i watched
him two nights ago and i when i we i
watch
my brothers are all start watching so we
kind of talk about it what do you mean
i'll be like hey i'm watching patrice oh
that was you texting yeah i thought you
were playing games like you're what are
you doing right now i'm sorry i'm sorry
okay you're texting people like my
brothers or your actual brothers you're
like yo i'm going to watch them stand up
yeah they're close
we had the i talked the other night
about like who makes us laugh the
hardest
you talk to your brothers often like
this
yeah that's [ __ ] awesome
i never hear this
ever
they all live here i've never heard of
anybody talking to their siblings like
that's awesome
well yeah man we but we are all two
years apart so we're all pretty close
sister's two years of cartoons
he goes
but um yeah and he knows all of them
pretty well too yeah
then your uncles yeah yeah i would hope
you know man yeah i mean
you said like they've introduced i've
introduced them yeah you know they've
come by a couple of times yeah uh but
yeah that no i
um we're all pretty close there was a
time where we all used to go out
together a lot
that's scary it was us for
and
my three cousins who were here we would
go out all together a lot of heads to go
out that's a lot of peep that's a game
yeah
that's a pickup game at least
yeah they got a couple of subs no for
real that's a lot of people
you got a three we got a three and three
on three half court right there that's
easy it's true with a ref yeah
yeah we used to we used to
go out together it was a it was a fun
you know then was it the
late 90s i guess in hollywood
still late night limbus get days it was
late 90s because you were born in 97.
yes yeah damn you missed this birth of
space jam
off by a year
i've seen it
plenty of times but you went there when
the mcdonald's toys were there you're
like yo can we get that [ __ ] oh my god
do you remember i mean you probably
didn't give a [ __ ] no you remember that
you were doing drugs
yeah
yeah
jesus christ i'm sorry you're right
yeah 97 yeah i had i had him in 97.
wow that's so long ago if you think
about it like that late
1900s [ __ ] the late 1900s holy [ __ ]
as it will be referred to in the not so
distant future adam mill made that one
of our guests he only talked you know
the late 1900s
oh dude don't say that
yeah that really feels terrible question
it felt like an insult
it's weird were you alive in the late
i know i'm only 1800s but yeah yeah
[ __ ] out of here you're making me feel
weird right now man i was born in the
late 1900s um question
comedian
raising you
you watching
any kind of comedy growing up
and or what was the first comedy you can
remember watching besides his
that's a great question besides his i
don't know i feel like it took me a
minute but
i mean i did also go out with you
also
besides that i'm talking about like
where you chose to go i said watch a
stand-up because you were alive in
youtube age yes
you grew up with that [ __ ] yeah
absolutely um
i don't really know if i really got into
comedy like really got into comedy
until i was probably about 18 or 19. oh
[ __ ] yeah i mean like i was into it and
i was always there and you know like we
always talked about his jokes and i knew
he was performing and telling those
stories because he always ran them by me
and was like can i tell this story or
this story or this story and i was like
yes yes no i don't like that one you're
just so accustomed to it i think is what
i'm getting like yeah
oh [ __ ] comedy shows all this is your
dad's profession yeah there was also a
couple times like when i was underage
that i went to like under drinking age
we would go to vegas
for a show or
something else and we'd come stay in the
casino with you but i couldn't go to the
shows because i couldn't get in oh i
didn't even think about all that so i
wasn't 18. so i couldn't get it so
didn't go much with him on the road like
in high school and i just
you were on a private jet
yeah one weekend one weekend okay it was
pretty dope i mean no it was he's like
don't throw a number on it but he's
private
one
absolutely that was that was pretty uh
amazing it's the only time i've ever
done that i definitely want to do it
again and we and you when i used to tour
a cable guy you came and did a weekend
on the tour bus yep that was dope as
well
the tour bus was super cool
i would have never left i just stayed in
there really that cool oh it's a pretty
cool way to get everything you needed i
just feel weird like hey man let's drive
this house good
yeah that's right laying down back here
hey but you basically but you're a fedex
package
because you go to sleep in one city and
you wake up in another truck driver
that's how i felt as a kid yeah i'd wake
up like where are we in l.a already
perfect
yeah
best thing like go to sleep [ __ ]
i hated truck driving it's so boring
there was no video games
i'd have [ __ ] to do when i was six yeah
i know my dad was on meth and like yo
that's why you slept for a day and a
half
on the side of the road we're just in
the just sleeping
pre-video games when i had to give my
kids benadryl to go to sleep on planes
the juice the juice you put in the juice
oh yeah yeah
you said the juice juice
the juice juice well you
where you would go to sleep
i drugged the others i can still do that
i can go to sleep anyways dude
that's a gift yes a gift
you know me
this dude just can be like hey i'm
gonna go to sleep right no
weird yeah but cool it's great it's
awesome i love being i love having that
talent oh that's amazing yeah i wish i
had that off switch
wouldn't it oh i'd be taller for sure
yeah my body was just elevated
you're doing too much down there
i i yeah
i wish i had that too got a couple fan
questions here bust them out man oh [ __ ]
the new thing we've been doing
mid-episode
at dopa's usual podcast on [ __ ]
instagram which we never [ __ ] say
i put up questions for josh and jacob
wolfe half the questions are about ask
jacob if he bought the porn with a
straight face shocker
okay
shocker all right well i mean
listen
do we need to explain what that question
means i just in case the fans that are
watching here don't know so i have
a joke that well it's a story
that i tell
my wife and i went out of town for a
weekend
and my parents jacob's grandparents came
over to the house
and
they stayed there for the weekend
and a month later i got 200
worth of porn charges on my direct
tv bill
jacob
blamed it on my parents his grandparents
said it was them
my parents don't agree
well that's not actually
i don't know yet can i yeah yeah hold on
wait wait wait can you tell them what
grandpa said okay so i asked my dad i go
hey man
because this has been going on a long
time i go hey man
did you
did you order that porn
and he goes jacob hasn't said anything
and i said no
and he goes well then i'm not gonna and
i was like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
so neither one of them will say anything
i've i've already said my part that's
the thing though is like it wasn't me
i told you what happened
my grandma my part is
and my part is it wasn't me it was
shaggy
it a hundred percent wasn't you i had a
joke prior to this as well
about me getting caught watching porn on
the computer yes
why why am i knowing it's free clicking
something on the tv hey he's got a
[ __ ] kid don't pay for porn two
hundred dollars that's like how much
[ __ ] fortunately you know what buying
porn on directv something an older man
would do thank you that was my next
point
oh
he was ready for that
holy
[ __ ]
that was great can i tell you i've been
on a lot of podcasts who've had
soundbirds
and that's one of the only times i
haven't thought why the [ __ ] did they
make that noise
that was so funny dude it was perf and
only that it was perfectly timed
oh it was you dropped it like the
[ __ ] sweet spot man
well done
so hold on back to it okay so your dad
bought it no here's the deal somebody
bought it it wasn't me
honestly outside perspective i believe
you okay let me just give you my
argument can i yeah okay
when i was
15 years old the same age he was
okay
i um
i discovered 976 numbers
those those were sex lines that you
would call and a recorded voice would
come on and do like a
three
to five minute spiel yeah
what did it sound like
hey
joey diaz why are your pants down barty
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
guys i'm off today man
i'm [ __ ] off he got me with his your
joint out i look at his pants and expect
marty's [ __ ] ass to be out like yo
oh [ __ ] uh i gotta think about it
what no not this time
um i didn't eat mushrooms yet
yeah
um what were you talking about you're
just really good you're really good at
this joke you're faking me man what were
we talking about porno story porno oh
your side and you were 15 years old and
976 numbers okay so 976 numbers were
like that was really
good so they they were like recorded
pieces and you know
you would jerk off and whatever
and so
my dad
[Music]
he sits me down
and he put he did exactly what i did to
jacob
he puts the phone ball down in front of
me
and i see all of the i see the
976 now
let me tell you what was embarrassing
there was 37.
oh
like in a row basically
i mean i took a couple minutes out of
here and there but in the same day oh
yeah you called it back in back to back
[Laughter]
i was just no it was probably over like
a week
like that that's a big [ __ ]
difference that's a big big difference
that's a world record it was probably
like over it was probably like over a
week
and um
he said uh
do you know anything about
this number and i was like no
and he said do you know what it is and i
said no
and he said
when you call it it's like a sex line
and i said um
well it's like it's educational and he
was like no
it's not educational
he said what a terrible thing
he said yeah what a terrible [ __ ] lie
he said he was like no he was like it's
like sexual
it's a woman i was like oh he said did
you call this number i was like no
and he said well you know it's just me
and your mom
and you living here
mom's a [ __ ] fruit so [ __ ] exactly
she says mom's wow he was like are you
saying this was
my dad's great with this he said are you
saying somebody broke in here
didn't take anything
didn't move anything around
and made these phone calls
on our phone
and i was like
it sounds pretty weird to me too but
i mean it wasn't me and he was like okay
and so
i will tell you like
he never
even though look i have had kids
and sometimes you let lies go
well he didn't bring it up after
oh he just like whenever he
if there was some point in time where he
was supposed to give me money he just
didn't
oh so he dropped the subject as soon as
you said he was just like listen
i'm just gonna take whatever money i was
supposed to give him
he's gonna pay this off
and that's what he just did he just was
he was like i know it was more like uh
look
i just wanted to see if you'd admit it
but
you didn't yeah so
we both know you need your beat off
story dude i know what happened right
like exactly dude like he he was to me
it was actually like a great lesson
because looking back i know he knew
i knew
i knew he knew and so he really it was
just a test yeah and i did not pass
i did i did not pass no you did not i
did not pass
but
but maybe you only called 32 times and
your dad called five times but how about
this feeding history how about this so
my point is my point is this is that
look my dad knows what an itemized bill
looks like you know who doesn't a 15
year old kid so you know who knows if he
orders anal party three you know who
knows it's showing up on the bill
my dad
there's no way he's ordering it and
having it show up on the bill
zero percent chance that is happening
now
there is a great chance that he was
scrolling through directv and at the end
of the 500s
there were porn channels and he was like
[ __ ] click on anal party three i
don't know and then it just came on he
was like holy [ __ ]
that was free no dude not free
not free it's like a [ __ ] court of
law right now no see so hey by the way i
rest
my case that my dad knows what an
itemized bill looks like
he does not no i got i got two more for
those well first of all you and mom uh
your mom did the bills on the kitchen
counter
so i've seen what an itemized build
advice i was younger that's just that's
just a small a smaller bottle second of
all um
second of all
come on in oh hey
[Music]
you can slide that on the wheel you're
fine
thanks
hi how are you doing you look [ __ ] up
really yeah i'm pretty happy i looked
thank you
you're good i'm good
there is exactly six you want to go
three each
yeah how many how what's the
eight so these are going to be point
seven times three two point one
yeah
oh wait do you want more is that one no
no no
i was trying to decide earlier
because i'm so much
i i'm so much smaller now and i don't do
as much as many much as he picks it up
with the three in his i'm so much
i do have a
a bit of a velociraptor hold on these
three
clever girl
i don't know if i should
just staring into my face
but i don't think i could do that
without water no you have no oh you were
contemplating the water not eating the
mouth
this whole time i thought you're like i
gotta do stuff no that i was
contemplating the amount too oh okay
yeah well let's call we can calm down
let's take two and see how we feel
what do you think
it's up to you they're pretty strong
josh isn't going to feel good but you
eat that straight caps too yeah so yeah
you're right
yeah this is one says try one wait like
no i don't want to try one
it's either two or three let's do two
and then we'll wait on the next one yeah
let's do that let's do it i know you i
know you can't swallow those pills
without water because you have no salt
no saliva yeah yeah
so you lose no they were stuck to my
tongue like like like um
like a hot day and you're like no it's
like a slime it was it was they were
stuck it might sound like almost like an
art
exhibit you know i mean they were like
they were they were like
they were like
they weren't going anywhere so i i could
have been like
they were stuck like something that's
nailed to the wall yeah yeah
that's right
like an immovable object
did i ever tell you about that
i have told you about this
did i ever send you that picture
of the what i did to that puma box
uh maybe
huh
well this the
piece of art and the upside down and the
frozen
all this together made me think at this
time
where
i was locked out of my house
and i had to go to the bathroom real bad
i like where this is going and i went
and i got
a shoe box out of that trash can
out of your own trash out of the out of
the front because you know trash day but
was it your trash my trash yeah totally
cool though shoe box
and
sat up against the side of my house
and [ __ ] in the shoe box okay
and i was pretty proud of it
took a picture
yeah i i i do remember now i definitely
got that picture but
i
um
you know i overlooked a couple things
you know
wiping all that stuff
should have taken the tissue out before
the important stuff
but
but
there's tissue in the shoe blocks take
the tissue out
and then [ __ ] in the box and then use
the tissue to wipe your ass he's
definitely got that picture if you
remember she was [ __ ] on top of the
tissue paper there was yeah absolutely
was you didn't even think about that
come on
i'm imagining it's him i've never had to
do that dance up while he shitty ass
took a picture or did he have to ask how
to take his ass
your house before you left in hollywood
in uh encino yeah oh it's i didn't i
wasn't at that i never yeah yeah the one
in encino before we moved out when i met
you at the house the tall one yeah i
said where did you [ __ ] isn't that a
shared driveway yeah that would have
been really uncomfortable
that's what you like i was just in the
middle of that courtyard that would have
been hilarious
that what a shocking thing to look out
your window and see
that'd be
kind of [ __ ] hilarious a smokey back
you're taking a [ __ ]
how polite though [ __ ] in the box yeah
well listen man it was my house so i
felt like i should but i left it out
there
i forgot
wait how long do you got back in the
house with the shitty [ __ ] that was what
i overlooked
i i uh it was
listen
i
felt really bad but i jumped in the pool
and i was like you know what
i was like you know what i i i
i hope this filter is extra strong and
it was your pool my pool oh god yeah
yeah it might get everybody pink
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah we put it
what reminded you to tell that story
again what what did we talk about that
you went this way
so the
[ __ ] the pill the pill being stuck to my
tongue and being upside down i had
forgotten about the box for so long when
i went out when i lifted it up
part of it looked like that what i
imagined those pills would have looked
like stuck to my tongue that's a deep
[ __ ] reference that was amazing that
is a deep i know i'm not the only person
that does [ __ ] like that in their head
yeah i'm very at one time but i'm very
visual
see what i mean i saw it all
i agree with you
that [ __ ] hurt my [ __ ] chest from
laughing bro
you [ __ ] on the [ __ ] tissue paper that's
so sweet
come on
i've never had to do that and i already
know that that's the first move is
taking oh shoot last night [ __ ] outside
[ __ ] on a church lawn
no
yeah were you coming out of church and
going in are you ready yeah the harlem
globetrotters came to mercedes what's
happening right now
what a sword
my town
because they play the sheriffs every
year for charity
and i'm sitting there like yo these
[ __ ] spit in the ba oh
and then there's no bathrooms oh no
and i ran from merced college
across the main hot street and of our
town and what do i do what do i what do
i do before i was like 11. so i'd have a
cell phone i was waiting for my grandma
to pick me up my mom was [ __ ] in the car
so i just waited
and i hit behind a bush and i had to
take a [ __ ]
in the
front lawn of a church
at night
sorry and i'm like yo these leaves
these leaves
and i remember i looked down like
there's shitty leaves everywhere
[Music]
the last time i took a [ __ ] outside
yo
by the way i'm sure you were like he'll
forgive me
oh i'm not a religious person oh yeah
taking a [ __ ] on the lawn
it's okay with me i had to yeah
sanctuary right no i'm listen i'm with
you in safe space asylum right gotta do
[ __ ] if you should be able to sit on a
lawn
she just popped in and dropped the
mushroom down like a magical fairy that
was so crazy
that was [ __ ] awesome oh before i go
i mean before i go before i get forget i
asked you what's the first stand-up
special you ever watched that you can
remember
uh
carlin okay that was like 40 minutes ago
my bad but i had to ask that question
yeah i think so
okay about i remember watching like um
comedy shows before that like what what
do you mean by that like
the improv used to have a show oh in
person no no no on tv oh wow evening at
the improv
um comedy central obviously had some
i know maybe it was pretty company
central it has to be because if it's
your first time you're right but it was
like i think mostly evening at the
improv so they were due there was a show
called the evening of the improv and i
don't remember what channel was on but
bud friedman used to host it and there
were comics on there and they used to
film it at the
i think the santa
maybe the melrose above
yeah there used to be an improv in santa
monica i think
and so but yeah
and so that's what i remember on tv and
that's what made me want to try it like
the first time i ever got on stage i was
15.
no [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah where i didn't
know this um at a place called the iron
horse in northampton massachusetts
and um
[Music]
yeah man my parents had to drive me
there
what did you i want to know what 15 year
old josh said on stage i can tell you
what my very first joke oh
i'm ready
so
first of all
i'm i'm wearing acid wash jeans
a mesh shirt
you were popping you were tight
okay you were cool right there i had
some
[ __ ]
debatable still wearing i had some for
me i had some chunky whatever i said
like
i had some chunky white
high tops
and the jeans were tucked in okay i had
i was wearing a baseball hat i had a
thick silver
chain not like a rope but like when king
tut would have wore you know what i mean
one of those
and a mullet
bob
and so
i would i said hey everybody my mom and
dad were in the front row this big mtv
era though yeah dude i was trying to
remember mtv was very influential dude i
wanted to i remember wanting to be dan
cortez we talked about this first time
yeah then i did a nickelo or a nintendo
[ __ ] interview thing and we brought
the picture
you're probably dressed exactly like
that picture
pretty much what he described fish not
long hair
that's pretty much what he just
described i mean so it was and um my mom
and dad were in the front row and i said
hey everybody i'm josh i'm 15 years old
i'm really nervous
this is the first [ __ ] time i'll be
able to [ __ ] swear in front of my
[ __ ] mom
[Laughter]
and uh
yo
the crowd
it was
now the rest of the jokes were terrible
the rest of the jokes were terrible it
was a comedy club or just like uh open
mic
but they weren't a [ __ ]
up they were not they were not ready for
that nobody
was ready for that i wasn't no no no
it was a
and the story i closed on
was a story about
you know my mom and dad both had
terrible gas when i was growing up
and we were driving down the freeway
once
and we were in the way way back you know
with the seats that face the back
and national lampoon yeah man and um
my dad pulled over and he was he told my
mom he was like hey
we were on the mass pike he was like hey
you got to get out for a minute she was
farting so bad there's a window we're
all running
didn't he was like you got it
and she was like what and he goes
methane you guys just like lithius she
goes she goes what do you want me to do
he goes you just gotta walk it off or
something
[Laughter]
it was like
eat as a kid
we ate real healthy dudes what the [ __ ]
happened
we ain't real healthy my parents they
we just ate healthy
we didn't they were we just did it's not
like they're related
and they
look my my mom used to
has always had a garden for as long as i
could remember so she grew a lot of the
food that we ate
the [ __ ] did you guys grow up yeah yeah
no what were you growing
you had to pull over your car
you had to pull over your vehicle to go
yo you smell like [ __ ]
get out of here yeah yeah there's a
probably a lot of a lot of high protein
diet probably
probably a lot of vegetables a lot of
raw vegetables probably i don't remember
when i wrote this but my dad my dad had
a gas problem they both
you know
farted a lot
of apple doesn't fall far from the dream
yeah but like he
i've tortured him with farts his whole
life i i've been farting in his mouth
many times no i've never done the fight
yeah never to an extreme but he was like
never giving a pink eye no no when i was
a teenager he would let one go and then
lock the windows yeah oh my dad's like
that he's an [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
listen it's funny and i don't want to be
the only one who admires it like what
the [ __ ]
that's funny especially when they're
little they're right at the right level
you want barbie
yeah
so good no hold on before you guys got
here
we're talking about a movie called the
mid 90s have you seen it
anyway in the in this in one of the
scenes like a little 30 year boy's
yelling at his mom i mean screaming [ __ ]
you she just picked him up from jail or
something and marty
goes
genuinely oh [ __ ] show one of my kids
talking to me like that he literally
said [ __ ] someone's jaw's coming off
i got so mad at this i don't know he got
genuinely mad talking about this he's
like i wish one of my [ __ ] kids would
start
the littlest girls
little camp
i'm imagining one movie my daughter
asked us to watch together as a
sitting family getting
crazy in the living room
heated throwing his hat into 20 years
there's me interviewing cam on a podcast
for his
star athleticism
one time my dad i remember he said jaw
me he'd rip my jaw i feel like kids just
should understand that that like that's
why
i don't know you have a different
approach to josh
yeah what do you do with the kid that's
screaming [ __ ] you [ __ ] in your face
and he's [ __ ] 15. i
i honestly don't know because it never
happened yeah it's tough
because it's as it's different you have
to maintain respect a hundred percent
i have to be able to end your world that
you have to understand that
that it only works
yeah listen man so that never happened
to me with like
somebody who could inflict harm on me if
i let them go too far you know what i
mean
yeah they have to know that
yeah i think they have to know that they
can't that's there's gonna be lying in
the house
you know
but i don't know man because it's never
happened to me so i'm not missing on the
world that ever i just the rage i felt
yeah that little [ __ ] tough tough one
did you know i i i mean
i'm sure he cursed me up and down once
the door was shut but he never but he
never did it to my face [ __ ]
christmas story dad
cousin under your breath man
makes you live long
yeah i mean
what what's the time
you remember
that you were the maddest of me
um i don't know i think i feel like i
have one from when i was like
like a kid
where i was
pitching in a baseball game
and
i was playing well and but i had a
couple people get on base and you came
to pull me out of the game
and i was like no i want to stay in it
and you really coach he he coached me
pretty much up all the way until it's
difficult
yeah
and so he came out on the mountain he
was like you're done and i was like no
i'm not i was like i got one more out
like
i want to get this batter like i'm not
coming out and you were like you're
coming out like we already got somebody
coming in
go take a seat on the bench you did
great but you're out and i was like no
and i just threw a fit on the mound
how old were you uh
12.
very bad news bears ish
12.
[Music]
um and eventually i he took the ball
from me and i went out and i took my
glove off and i threw it in the dugout
and i just sat there
i just sat there on the uh on the bench
just
crying pissed just so mad and uh he put
somebody else in the game
um they they got the next batter got out
of the ending came in
and i was just sitting there and you
were like come on time to buck up trying
to be there for your team and i was like
no
and he brought me he literally picked me
up and brought me to
the minivan that was parked just outside
outside the dyno diamond on the street
and he brought me in there and he put
the keys in and he's like you're gonna
sit in here for the rest of the game oh
and he was like you're not gonna come
out you're not gonna contribute you're
gonna sit in the van for the rest of the
game nice and i'll come drive you home
when it's over that was his version of
john and
yeah and i like that
there's
uh mostly because i go back to that
trust thing
is that like there's no when that
happens he's there's no question about i
and purposely i picked him up so he knew
that i
at any time could pick him up
do you know what i mean like more any
time
it's important like you can do it
without doing it and just by lifting him
up he was first of all a little shocked
and i just carried him sure
just i'm like but but but like
also important dude for me anyways
not to lose control you can be in charge
you can be in charge
and you can be stern and you can make
somebody do what you want them to do
without losing control and i think you
lose credibility when you lose control
do you know what i mean because then you
go back to that trust thing dude like i
can't trust you to get keep your [ __ ]
together like now now i'm what if i do
this are you going to lose your [ __ ] if
i do this or if you you know what i mean
and so i'm not saying i never lost my
[ __ ] everybody loses they're [ __ ]
it happens but that was for me the
reason why i tried not to
all right
hold on
did you guys win
did we win that game did you guys
i wanted to know i don't know why
him in the car yeah
see i'm [ __ ] in the van like [ __ ]
this yeah i lost didn't we
lost huh yeah that would have been a
tough lesson for me to try to teach
[Laughter]
i think we did end up winning the game
yeah thank god
i was still super pissed oh but like
later on in my like
my teen years like in high school
i don't know
anything i got like grounded for i
[ __ ] like deserved it so there was
nothing i could like i could be mad at
him but like what'd you get grounded for
i want to know what you got grounded for
for a whole summer right
like tv
the whole summer tv video games like tv
yeah where you're like you're grounded
for the summer like yeah [ __ ]
that's all you got as a parent that's
all that's that's i've never been
grounded first
i had no i had no phone i had no tv i
had no
video games
uh did you leave the house
oh wait that's i did i could leave the
house to go ride my bike to the park to
play basketball oh dude that's that's
that's cool there was one time he was i
forget if you were 12 or 13.
but you know old enough
where
and for me anyways we lived like a mile
from beeman park
studio city
pretty safe place
so i remember one time a friend of yours
was over and i was like why'd you guys
just ride your bike to the park
and he was like all right
and the kid was like
you have to call my mom i don't think
i don't think she's gonna let me do that
i'm like
why not
and he was like well you can call and
ask her and she was like yeah i'm not
i'm not comfortable with them going to
the park by themselves
and i was like i can't believe it
at 12. i mean look man they shouldn't be
out
partying all night but you you
we were on our bikes and i
i hate when people say it's a different
time
is it or are you just more aware that
there are people call you know they're
just more aware yeah that's awareness
for sure and so like people are still
just as gross yeah yeah
they're in the as they were before
not probably worse yeah and so like
but like it's also important for me at
some
point for him like especially it just
me not be there all the [ __ ] time
i would like to smoke sweet sometimes
without you bugging me through the
window the window like a neighbor
genuine laugh like i remember that kid
go
over there
hiding should i used to do that for my
[ __ ] oh
my cousin but he's not my kid but still
like yo he's a little baby
check that out holding the bong on the
other side of the window
so cool
yeah just chilling out smarty every time
i call marty and there's an up angle
barney's smoking weed away from his kids
real quick
every time i'm in the closet am i in the
am i in the cabinet oh okay you're
packing balls puts me in the cabin he
packs areas cabinet
do they do they know the smell
no i always usually do it outside
yeah like in like outside of the garage
and ha and how i mean how old do you
think
it'll be like you're for in until your
first kid goes thirteen-year-old she
watches the [ __ ] podcast oh yeah she
knows what's up she knows she knows i
never thought about [ __ ] like that
friends that watch the podcast and [ __ ]
so like they they like she'll be
facetiming her friends and sometimes
they'll start [ __ ] geeking out and
[ __ ] because they
like over thomas and [ __ ] watch the show
yeah
so
that ship kind of sailed i don't know it
didn't really wasn't really something we
really even talked about but yeah i
never thought about it yeah she watched
the show of course she said you smoke
weed out of a pipe
62 times yeah the [ __ ] goes hard
on the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah i
keep it i've always kept it like not
like they don't kids don't know i'm
[ __ ] nothing oh yeah every time you
go there there's no ounce of
a drop of wheat anywhere yeah no i'm not
meant to smell
no no he's working out in the garage by
the door like outside yeah i smell guys
i do and i got he hooked me up with this
little dabbering thing oh so much dab
right now the best thing i've ever heard
he doesn't really smoke weed that much
he's just been smoking [ __ ] hash
on top of a hat what dude we took a
[ __ ] i gave him a dab out of a really
crazy rig
and marty took like a point three and
went
did you just barely cough
it's that winter lung from the east
coast the winter long he's got that
strong hard solid brick lung yeah by the
way the winter long that is what the
game of thrones new series is about
that's that's what does that mean winter
long it's called winter long game of
thrones i just made that up i've never
seen it
yeah that would be a good one though
game of thrones winter long i know we
haven't eaten them a lot i'm gonna take
that other one i feel like josh you're
gonna [ __ ] with the dabs a little bit
though that's so nice you're dead fresh
here's why i don't dad and i can here's
me and i can tell you why i don't like
to dab
i love
weed i love the
i love the ascension of the weed i think
it's almost perfect
how high you get and i love it with
edibles
but just like i don't like
coke because i'm normal and now i'm
[ __ ] not
do you know what i'm saying you don't
like the instant [ __ ] up nah that's cool
that's not for me
that's cool i like you know what you
want that's awesome you like to chill
and go i like the guys
i get it i like it i like to glide into
it i like it because it's so fast this
is the only time i can chill and puff a
joint is when i'm here really so i kind
of the little for you it's an efficiency
thing yes because marty's editing it but
i like it too
he can't be smoking yeah it's stronger
so you take one one little [ __ ]
sesh off the [ __ ] dab rig is like oh
marty's going hard guys
every time i facetimes me like you're
dabbing again
how long does one dab last how long will
one dabble do you
i mean you sit there i'm i take little
tiny [ __ ] dabs compared to these guys
like i'm talking like tiny little
[ __ ] dabs you sit there and chief on
the [ __ ] things for like you probably
go through a gram and how long two days
yeah yeah yeah it's kind of like a gram
is like an eighth of weed basically yeah
it's reasonable it's basically the same
exact thing to me i'll sit on a gram of
wax or an eighth of weed for like two
days and one hit off your dab how long
are you high
like an hour or two
but but it's also a more it's more
expensive right like to to buy water
in my world that's the same my eighth of
weed and a
gram of wax are about the same oh guys
if you're talking about efficiency and
price
hash and wax is the cheapest way to ever
smoke weed or ever get high
really get one gram of live resin you
take a 0.1 which is you know you have 10
of those in the gram take a point one
and if you don't dab a lot you're gonna
be high as [ __ ] for about two hours
and that one grandmother cost you thirty
five dollars
it's about an eighth that's about an
eighth that's a yeah that's that is what
he's saying it's accurate yeah but some
hash like the hash my friend may i smoke
hash rosin yeah it's really expensive
but that's like a hundred a gram but
it's a different level of like
oh [ __ ]
it's like
it
to you the strongest [ __ ] i can smoke do
you remember
the first time you remember thinking
oh this is good weed
yes
yes when was that
i was walking through merced merced
where i'm from it gets like 110 120 in
the summer it's hot
i walk i was walking and i remember
thinking
i'm [ __ ] so i smoked a blunt of
purple weed i remember looking at like
so now i'm looking back it's good
not the best [ __ ] weed of all time
but i'm like that's some pretty good
weed
so as a kid i was like 15 i'm walking
with my sister that was a dick to me so
i was like oh [ __ ] she was invited let
me go with her to her friends okay if i
could but her friends i knew
but they're she's like don't hang out
with my little brother kind of thing you
know what i'm saying so it's like oh
you're letting me go over there okay so
i'm drenched in [ __ ] sweat i get
there i smoke out of a bong which i
don't have so i got [ __ ] high
instantly i rip it and that's when i'm
like oh and i almost did i had a heat
stroke i went in the bathroom anybody
know and i grabbed one of their towels i
wiped my whole body off because i was
pouring come on i drink water out of the
faucet and i walked out like i'm fine
i'm fine because everybody thinks you
took one
out
get your little brother out of here
but they don't know i smoked a [ __ ]
giant blood on the way there and i
didn't drink water and then i ripped the
bong so i tried to hide i didn't think
my sister knows yeah that's the time
sorry gabe i use your whole [ __ ] hand
sweaty as [ __ ] yeah
he's done worse things with that hand
towel 150 there's so many dudes over
there
oh you know i was probably bad that i
used that towel
yeah
yeah
yeah it was a while ago though yeah
you've probably been tested since then
you're probably fine i'm okay yeah
you're good you could think about that
yo
my okay
when we were driving
my oh my
my older brother to college so we lived
in massachusetts we were going to drive
him to florida on the way to florida
was pittsburgh where my oldest brother
went to college
and so
um
he wasn't it was
he wasn't going with us
but he was like hey you can stay at
night because we didn't really have any
money we need to save money in the
fraternity
and so
dude [ __ ] have you heard this tom
wolf story i don't think so
so we walk in
and
it's like
i don't know how to explain not messy
it's dirt it's
and there's like
a little bit of water everywhere
and then down by the
the bathroom the standing water
about you know three four inches
and so we're all just looking down the
hallway like oh my god you're with your
dad my dad and my brother
and so we're just like ugh
so
my dad's like you guys take this room
i'll take this room
and we're okay so we're in the
fraternity it's just [ __ ] gross
we get up in the morning
i'm like oh my god how'd you sleep he
was like my brother's like so gross
let's get the [ __ ] out of here it's so
gross let's just keep driving
and um
we go out to see where my dad is
we hear somebody
in the bathroom
just kind of you know
having a chuckle with himself
how come is my dad in walking barefoot
in that standing water he just went in
the bathroom to shower he goes showers
shower feels good boys
he was like you should hop in the water
shot and i was like
what what
do you have any idea what you're
standing in he goes no but i just washed
it it's fine
this [ __ ] i don't know if that's
how that works dude but that's the same
dude he dropped that hot dog
on the ground at fenway park you're dead
and he and he ate it
my man
my man
hey look i i will attest you don't waste
the fenway frank you know what i'm
saying so you remember
what are you doing he was like what it's
my hot dog and i was like i know but
it's on the ground man like it's on the
ground and he was like yeah but
he's like just you know my feet have
been here like
that logic is [ __ ] stupid
so i walk my feet on this ground it's
fine i've been i've been like i've been
sitting here nobody's [ __ ] you what
do you mean it was built in 1911. you
know what i mean like it's just the
black plague
it's been through a lot it's been
through a lot yeah yeah absolutely
that's that's
oh wait you're telling me the first
episode we ever came on you we talked
about your dad and you were
watching the show
and you agree like yeah i would agree
he's in very good shape for being an
older man
your dad and then you're saying he's
eating raw [ __ ] vegetables and
walking barefoot
yeah he's built up some immunities uh he
he was like what five nine five ten in
college you could dunk a basketball off
two you could dunk a basketball standing
out with two likes i'll be five ten i
think about ten man
crazy
we're gonna find out their [ __ ] dad
jax elaine's cousin or something
what
is right now that would be awesome his
jewish cousin jack lalanne berg
do you see what i'm saying here elenovic
i like that one yeah i like that one i
think that one's better
no hold on yeah so you're wait
your dad can dunk a basketball yeah
not anymore it could
so your dad like goes on runs and [ __ ]
nah he plays golf pretty much every day
oh so he's active yeah golf isn't the
easiest [ __ ] he also goes to the gym at
86. he also goes to the gym four days a
week
yeah i think he's got that down oh yeah
just because he's playing golf so much
and lazy [ __ ]
stop it that lazy [ __ ]
yo what yeah he's
this is cool yo this dude
um
[Music]
shot his age in golf he shot an 82. i
don't know what that means i'm not good
i don't so for those of you who are
listening who don't know
you know it's the lower the score the
better
and like a professional golfer shoots
they shoot in the 60s and 70s
but like as you get older it's obviously
harder
to
shoot below whatever your age is
oh that's a thing yeah so when you say
he shot his age or he shot by those age
so
for him to be his age into shooting 82
was like
crushing it
yeah this
i still can't beat him
none of you can beat him you know how to
play golf though no
no
no i'm not compared but saying if you no
no i like to go out and have a good time
yeah i like to try smoke joints i'll
[ __ ] a golf course up
yeah well all these from david's boy i
yeah
you know what i like doing also my
grandfather
it's fun to fool old people
but my grandfather
he's my grandfather's such an avid
golfer wait did you say your grandfather
is an avid golfer was was oh they hold
your dad is 86 years old yeah he's our
father you're 88. 105 golfer no this
dude with an avid i have a golfer he
loved the game
and um
so
one of your clubs is called the driver
right
and you're only supposed to hit that off
of your first shot yeah you're not
supposed to use it in the fairway
it's hard to hit
off the grass if you're not if you don't
have it teed up just the way the angle
is so my grandfather had terrible vision
you know he wasn't eyeballing me from
but i told him i strictly used the
driver
so he but he never saw me put the t in
the ground
so i was wow i was just whacking him
off the fairway and he would i would
love it it was so
if we come back to dinner he was like
joshua was at it again today whacking
him out of the fairway with that driver
and i was such a little [ __ ] it made
the whole day worth it i'm like only i
knew i pulled the joke that was it
that's all that mattered to me
just enough that i was like that's right
oh yeah fool them again
[Applause]
it's such a satisfying you know the
thing is that is equally as crazy it's
like
the story like what are you gonna do to
him what happened with your grandpa's
call
oh it's for you
that's exactly how he fell to like oh my
god [ __ ] yeah
look at how high your dad is right now
and it's funny to say it that way yeah
it's so funny because you're [ __ ]
grown up
it's so odd like you said earlier it's
weird i'm a grown man for her son
it's odd yeah and that he's the
designated driver that's cool though
yeah
so i haven't just been
seen on this journey yeah that's why
i've been chilling out taking a couple
you know what i'm saying
it's all good but
this is
yeah i'm dd it'll be all right
you're good i haven't said anything in a
long time well i've just been also you
know listening to the conversation
listening to your story yeah about you
fooling your grandpa i loved it
but i think he would have loved it too
let me tell you something if i would
have let him in on it he was so funny my
grandfather was like one of the funniest
like i did that because
honestly like
that kind of stuff
because he was so funny like he
okay there was one time
he
he was sitting down i was in the back
seat of the car and he sat down
in the front seat and he goes whoop and
he kind of sat back up and thinking what
happened he goes just sat on my nuts
and i was like oh
buddy
that's a bummer
but also it's like yeah you made it to
an old age man yeah
but but like you know i was eight i
didn't need to hear that but
but still you know
funny one of the funniest dudes so like
when i say
fool an old person like
would have loved to have been tricked to
be in on the he wasn't in on it but he
would have loved it if he was yeah i
could have i could have been but i did i
did that was for me yep that's it
sometimes you just gotta take one for
yourself
don't you ever pull a joke
and sometimes you're the only one who
knows
i'm the master of it i i love those
before i started dating rosie i had her
convinced that behind my giant joe
montana poster i had a 8x8 montana
poster
because i my room was connected like
right next to my roommates we had a
house
and i convinced her before she ever
started dating when she was my friend
like oh yeah behind this is a door that
leads because my house was built in 1910
in merced like yeah there's a door it
connects to me in g business room but
it's kind of weird having a room
connected to both our rooms i just put
this montana poster on
we started dating like a year and a half
later she moved into my [ __ ] house
we're dating we're redecorating and she
takes it off because where's the [ __ ]
door i'm like what the [ __ ] are you to
oh oh wait a second i planted that seed
a long [ __ ] time ago and i forgot how
good did that feel to get that
unexpected payout
did you for
for a second just sit back and think
she's been thinking about that for a
year and a half oh yes and what's even
better is that
you forgot and it was still happening oh
oh those are so satisfying they're like
it's like a residual income surprise
yeah no yeah it's it's mailbox money oh
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's mailbox money it was
funny for a while because i remembered
then i forget and now i remember again
it's like finding money yeah yeah yeah
spending money in your jeans i did that
the other day it was great so good
you're like oh okay okay so you do like
that i get what you're saying perfect
yeah i've done that to a lot of people
that's a good time i've done stupid [ __ ]
to everybody but that was my favorite
one
that's your favorite one i think that
was my favorite one because
she had so many expectations of like oh
our rooms connect what's this extra room
gonna be like
by the way that is
quite a good one to have somebody
convinced yeah that is a reason
you want to hear my best one yeah and it
just ended two days ago how long had it
been happening
13 years
my little brother rocco
you ready for this yep
my monty carlo my
it's like my uh
it's a six you know like the old monte
carlos the super sport once yeah
when he was a kid he picked him up from
school he was like five six i pick one
from school and take him you know what i
mean just because like his little
brother
he was i convinced him i had nos and
then the car was self-driving because he
would love transformers but he was in
the back seat buckled
he couldn't see that my knee was driving
i'd be like look
say activate like activate and i'm just
go look we're driving but i would turn
you know because it's a big old wheel
you can just move it with both legs now
you can't it's like power steering well
not power steering but it was easier to
move that wheel but i convinced him that
i had nos in that car
because i had a button right here in the
front but it was just an alarm button
that beeps when you know the alarms on
so i would press it gas the [ __ ] car
as fast as i could
and every time they hit the doss
[Music]
look back at him
and then he was talking to his friend
the other day he facetimed he goes
thomas do you still have knowledge in
your mind
oh my [ __ ] god
of course i do yeah no i don't know
how can you even ask me i got it on all
my cars now
yeah that's good yeah that would have
been [ __ ]
what did you say instead it's morocco
how dumb are you that's a [ __ ] alarm
yeah did you really like are you kidding
me you're about to be 18 years old
what's wrong with you that car was
parked at your house for four for three
years i left it over there he cleaned it
for him like didn't you see the nos
tanks there would be nos tanks you're a
car kid you don't know so yes that one
that's a heroine
oh i was like oh my god you really saw
oh [ __ ] yeah i think my favorite one
ever
love this
you had some small ones that were your
favorite ones which i started doing back
to you as well when we lived in the same
house that's what she said yeah
which ones the
how about the one where you would go
into the freezer
he used to eat a lot of lime popsicles
growing up like the ones from trader
joe's they're super good the square ones
yeah yeah yeah just like yeah this is a
fruit popsicle
and he used to just uh he would always
take the last one
but instead of throwing the box out he
would put the box back in a free [ __ ]
monster
that's not cool that's [ __ ] up
actually my kids do that [ __ ] that'll
send you into our rage and so
or if he comes in the room eating one
i'm like oh you know what that sounds
like a great idea let me go get one he's
like it's the last one you son of a
[ __ ]
you dumb [ __ ] can i tell you he
just sends me to the fridge to wait for
me to go oh what the hell man so that is
my all time because i could have just i
could have just eaten it and gone into
my room but if i eat it and go into his
room he sees it and he thinks that looks
good
knowing full well that i left the empty
box in the freezer free meditation just
so i could hear him scream from the
other room
what the hell or what the [ __ ] or why my
favorite one is why are you like this
[Laughter]
that's the title of the episode oh my
gosh
yo my cheeks actually it's like you know
where they kind of spasm sometimes
it's happening it [ __ ] hurts that one
is my i saw why you like this i started
doing it back to while i still had a
couple years left in the house he did
this [ __ ] and every time i would take
one i'd be like i'll be like all right
i'm going to bed
and i'd be like and he would hear me
rattle with the paper and you go do you
get a second one for me and i'll be like
no go get your own [ __ ] limestone man
like yeah i'm going to bed i would just
sit and close my door but wait right on
the other side of my door just to hear
because he would either go oh god damn
it or he would laugh because he know he
got yeah he knows he know he got got so
he would just sit there and
and becomes a teacher yeah and i would
just say
[ __ ] i would just go inside my room
and turn on some netflix and be like hey
i'm gonna make one of these make one of
these shows
yeah but it was good for him i i mean i
love it
that's actually [ __ ] hilarious yeah i
don't want to be the only one
doing it yeah i started
yeah go drive my car no gas in it
that's the ultimate oh you oh you want
to know the most you want to know the
best one about me driving his car
we're working on joshua show i was 18
years old i had my license for probably
about six months at this point in time
and i went and dropped you off at the
airport one weekend it was probably a
friday morning
do i know this yeah you know this oh
okay it was it i saw so the deal was
when he went out of town
uh i could use his car
and but the deal was i had to drive him
to the airport when he left and pick him
up every time that he's like a [ __ ]
amazing deal for you
except except after a saturday night at
sunday at lax at 7am
stay up while there are people at my
house like i have to get up go get him
and then come back to all of my friends
either just waking up or still sleeping
so there were some days but i was like
yeah but i did have a car to take me to
school and i had a car on the weekend so
it was worth it definitely
i drop him off one morning and i'm on my
way back
this is the only time i've ever been
pulled over by highway patrol or anybody
for
anything
i get pulled over in his car guy officer
comes up and goes hey how you doing i'm
like good what's what seems to be the
issue and he goes well your tags are
expired
and i was like
i was like well this is actually my
dad's car he goes you have like all the
license registration i go here's my
license like i think it's in here thank
god you told me where it was so at one
point in time in my life so i knew how
to i think i might have said hey these
tags might be expired at some point in
time no no no no
he never said that and even if he did
say it guess what it's your job to get
the time
100
man and so i got i got pulled over and
they're like it's just a fix-it ticket i
just have to
show up to the courthouse at like 8 a.m
on this day
pay like a
i don't know it was like a 50 dollar
fine
but no more didn't i go
didn't you go no you went to sh you went
to work i went to
the courthouse to get it done and then
came into work that's right that's right
i didn't go heated
because it was on my nose
but which which parking ticket that i
have to go to court on
what mine wasn't a parking ticket mine
was a highway patrol ticket why was i
like a citation no i mean it was one of
those was it with you with your head out
the window you had to put your trouble
for that
we were like 400 feet from our house
getting off the freeway
and this highway patrol highway patrol
dude not a cop highway patrol had his
head out the window like a golden
retriever which was hilarious yeah
and super funny and his face was the
wind was blowing his face
but this highway
wasn't on the highway he pulled off just
off the base of the highway and out of a
[ __ ] car wash yeah
he pulled out of a car wash and we drove
right by him he saw him and he went
oh i had no idea i was like hey what's
going on you know he was like
his head was out the window and i was
like
who's he's like yes and i was like yeah
he was
acting like a dog
which is probably true yeah not gonna
lie and the guy was like well he can't
do that i'm like for real okay
so but he was like i'm gonna have to
write you a ticket i'm like what yeah i
went to court for that ticket did you
win
yeah because he didn't show up why would
you show up why he's not even a lawyer
they never show up he's like i'm like
i'm like going downtown for the law head
of i think it is so i think it's
something like reckless endangerment
yeah
just your head
it was like a child
oh you were a kid oh yeah i was probably
like 11.
yeah he wasn't like two you know how
crazy it is but he wasn't he wasn't like
i didn't have him out the window by his
diaper like michael jackson
you know i mean he he was like 11
and buckled up
not like you know what i mean he just
had his head out the window my dad's a
truck driver and every time we hit a
dirt road
my thing was you know how the there's
handles right on the outside of diesel
doors yeah i would get to stand on it
outside of the truck hold the handle
and he would drive down the road to do
the lows for like two three miles i'd be
hanging off the [ __ ] truck
that [ __ ] was sick we never got in
trouble that's something you got your
first joy was
i used to try to do no feet and hold
like it was actually like ah
it was pretty dangerous actually but
yeah that doesn't sound great before
yeah i probably shouldn't have been
doing that that was on [ __ ] drugs
yeah you know what that be kind of tight
get out of the car under the truck my
sister would be on the other one
on the other side we're only going like
10 miles an hour yeah five still
probably a little young for that
for sure yeah yeah i started driving at
five my dad was a tweaker when i was a
kid bro i always started driving i've
been driving my whole life um
i when i was five years to sit on his
lap and learned how to shift and steer
but i'm on his lap and then like six
he'd be sitting next to me
like oh you know there's a lot of space
in the diesel he'd be kneeling next to
me
like hands on it with me and then like
seven or eight he would sit over there
and he would let me drive on the [ __ ]
freeway
foot on the pedal and everything
my dad is a monster my sister did it too
so i'd be sitting there but my dad's
right there like watching me like you're
good you're good you're good good you're
like slow down slow down like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] but he would shift for me
because i can't downshift as a
eight-year-old yeah probably but i
learned how to downshift at like 10 on
the grapevine because my dad just drives
back and forth so i've been driving my
whole [ __ ] life i hate i won't drive
a stick shift it's so boring
yeah not anymore yo how do you you can't
do anything else in a car if you have to
do this i got [ __ ] to do with i don't
know i know it sounds dangerous but i
got this other [ __ ] to do but do they i
don't even know if they sell do they
sell sticks anymore they have to
definitely they have to marty they sell
sticks anymore
[ __ ] joint rolling this shit's got
paddles on it that's uh you know i think
that's kind of the new yeah like i can't
imagine any new car outside of like a
race car
i have no [ __ ] idea i got to be
honest that's a good question i would
say
when's the last time you were in a car
that was
older than 19
i don't even know
but no 2000 cars have a stick shift
right i don't think so no uh
my buddy of mine throughout high school
drove a 2009 scion tc that was stick
shift i don't know what that is messiah
you know what a scion is i don't know
what that is
scion the car square ones uh no they
were like they were like rounded at the
edges though right and they had a
spoiler at the end too they are the ones
that had the little hamsters in the
commercials
that was that was like the cube
or the nissan q right something like
that yeah the scion tc had a stick in
like 2009.
really oh [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
yeah i mean i learned to drive on a
stick the first car that i had was
a station wagon that was four on the
floor
bbb and you can oh i could [ __ ] go to
empty uh parking lots and just
let's do donuts yeah in the station
wagon oh that back game
that's a heavy bag yeah dude it was a
good one uh
i [ __ ] loved having a stick as a kid
but i would hate it now yeah did you
ever take cars as a kid without people
knowing
not stealing
we
returned it we move okay so
people would
people would
warm up their cars in the morning those
mushrooms they're pretty good
people would people would
warm up their cars in the morning
and
we just moved them
you moved them so if you lived across
the street
and that dude lived there and you both
were warming up your car in the morning
you'd switch them we would just switch
them oh my god it'd be so upsetting
though you that was funny don't ever get
in my car again yeah you know that's
funny my dad was like my dad was like
hey
um
that's grand theft auto
and we were like nah we're just joking
we're just moving back and forth but
having a laugh and he's like yeah but
did you
take that dude's car i'm like no we
didn't take it it's right there he's
like but you took it
that's stealing it doesn't matter where
you left it
you took it and i was like
huh he was like i wouldn't do that
anymore they ever questioned you nobody
ever questioned you they knew it was us
we were asked not to do that again yeah
okay all right it's all yeah yeah
because we thought it was so funny
that's [ __ ] hysterical that's funny
my dad was like hey this is crazy you're
gonna get shot this is a real bad idea
you getting in somebody's car
i would never get another person that's
scary when it's running
super bad idea yeah not not at all
that's a trap yeah yeah that's way
riskier than what i was doing what the
[ __ ] not in the town i grew up in
actually
oh okay okay so you knew you were okay
doing it yeah so you were the bad kids
and that was the worst thing you did
that's not that bad yeah no we weren't i
wouldn't say we were back kids that
doesn't seem bad no we were back it
seems pretty funny yeah no it's pretty
harmless i think it is i really i really
like that story uh we we were not
we were not by kids did you ever take
the car without him doing
uh well when he was out of town and like
i like had like could use the car yeah
besides that i'm talking about when he
was like yo you can have the car besides
that point did you ever sneak the car
you had to have he's on the road well no
while he was on the road though i didn't
have to sneak the car i'm saying before
you were allowed to
no
whoa that's [ __ ] awe i mean that's
great
that's that you're a good [ __ ] kid
that's that [ __ ] the [ __ ] up quick he
was a good kid man pulled a good burger
put simba at him
ruined the whole [ __ ] side of the car
that's what would i just take my
grandma's cadillac a lot
where
my friend joe's just do drugs and then
come back
it was so tight
a brand new white [ __ ] cadillac with
the gold plates and [ __ ] it was cool hey
china decide if i should have this other
one hold on
i want to say something i took my other
one like what 15 minutes ago about six
seven minutes ago it just dropped
because i didn't have enough water and
it got stuck and i didn't want to like
it'll drop it'll drop so
on camera money when you're editing this
you'll see me like
it just like dissolved oh no
yeah i mean you i'm in the same
situation marty could you do us a favor
in the little refrigerator could you get
him another water of course because he
needs to drink actually oh actually
could you just get three of them i'm
sorry
here's our little interview sir thank
you man
yeah dude i wish i had a soundboard to
play [ __ ] waiting music right now for
marty that
uh heartbeat one was a bad joke it was
scary yeah yeah that was pretty funny oh
you know we won't do it but we had a
plan ah we didn't do it you know what we
had a plan to do to [ __ ] with you once
the mushroom's hit but this is like six
months ago for this down board and i was
going to pretend like what
what are you talking about i didn't get
one that would have been oh don't worry
we'll get you even though i told you
you're gonna forget and we'll get you
one day that's a 100 trick it's gonna
happen yeah you're gonna forget there's
no doubt about that i mean
30 minutes from now yeah i forgot we
were talking about the alligators and
that was today
what alligator exactly i [ __ ] forgot
we talked about in the beginning and how
they're dinosaurs oh yeah yeah that's so
republicans see
pelican style yeah dude um
they haven't fully hit me
what's up guys welcome to the mid-roll
ad read and this is one of our long time
sponsors this is manscaped before we
start do me a favor go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yola
that's 20 off your whole order anything
you buy plus free shipping guys it's
spring cleaning and what does that mean
you know what we're gonna say it's time
to shave your dick and balls all right
don't be gross we say it all the time
don't be nasty as [ __ ] yeah you can get
a razor but this is the iphone for your
dick it's just better it's gonna be
better and it's not just that they have
many more products toner cologne
underwear travel cases hair shampoo hair
conditioner it's not just for your dick
anymore but that's the staple and that's
what we're going to stand by so april's
testicular cancer society awareness
manscape has partnered with the
testiculars cancer society to bring more
awareness to this and it's actually
something that should be talked about
and you know manscape they're going to
do something hilarious it's for
testicular cancer and the slogan is we
save balls i love manscape so much guys
right now go to www.manscape.com
forward slash yolo that's 20 off
everything support the brands that
support us and i know this one is super
goofy this is one of my favorite
episodes let's get back to it
thank you thank you for everyone at home
this is a reminder to please drink some
water
barney what time we at right now i think
it's like 2 37 or something 2 20.
how did i know
this was going to be at least
what was that face
that was the co oh you're contemplating
do you need it
do you need it
how you feeling about how you feeling
right now how are you feeling right now
i mean
how do i see him
cool jeff how's your job the legacy on
the shoulder yeah you still you still
seem like you're on this planet what's
the clip i'm fun pleased with father not
to do drugs in front of him
yeah that's what it is that's what it is
do you need it yeah yeah yeah
are you sure that was genuine
high five yeah yes
yeah listen man
yeah i won't take that next one yeah i
mean yeah i feel like you're good i
don't know
i'm not saying i'm looking at you i'm
feeling it yeah i'm not saying no to it
completely because i like the chaos also
but you know
yeah no i mean
am i good i feel pretty good are these
walls going [ __ ] crazy
it's very subtle yeah yeah it's there
but it's like i don't i could totally
function
yeah like well then take the third [ __ ]
it
oh [ __ ] love that
if you feel fine
how long ago because i don't have a real
sense of time at least 30 minutes at
least maybe wait 10 more minutes you
know what monday
what i'm gonna stand up
oh it's the first time i've ever do it
do you know what i mean because that's
when you know how high you are push the
mic
that's true am i the only one who has
that theory you're right though what's
that let's say if you push the mic
you're going to smack yourself on it
yeah and take your headphones off so you
don't get dragged right down good no
stand but do you know what i'm saying oh
i get it awareness awareness
you know what i'm gonna stand is this
room is does this room
feel heavy
you look way tall like my arms ripping
you look like a giant we used to break
me okay by the way i'm definitely higher
than i was down there
[Laughter]
literally my perception is [ __ ] weird
yeah by the way you look like you're
literally you look like the tallest man
on earth feel huge right now what the
[ __ ] is happening isn't these low chairs
do you want me to stand up without
really maybe the motions
yeah you stand up let's see
this avatar body would do
because by the way when i stood up i was
like am i that tall i looked him and see
that tall is he standing on something
it's like when your shadow fully formed
never stopped are you guys all right do
you seem you're having an accordion of a
body you just kept going
you don't feel taller than usual
you
look taller than usual that's the
episode name
taller than usual you look like dude
giant if you look giant jack skellington
yeah yep i prefer slenderman oh dude it
was like
you're right it was like oh when's this
unfolding yeah when does that ride stop
like
you just kept going up and up
wow yeah remember we you guys both just
stood up you guys are related
oh yeah yeah these are pretty [ __ ]
but but did you feel taller than usual
no when i was standing up i just i just
think you're higher than usual
by the way that's a great name for an
album that was a uh joshua's an opener
higher than usual that's hilarious
uh marty how we look on this camera
since we stood up are we still good yeah
all right good yeah that's the first
time anyone's ever stood up on the show
first of all highness track
no you stood up to see how high you are
what a gauge don't do you never do that
i have never done that in my life
yeah all the times of how high i am
yeah i don't think i've ever gotten
never gone huh i just i've laid down
but i feel like i laid down when i stand
up
is when i know how high i am because i'm
never as high as sitting down as i am
standing at i guess i feel you on that
like when i'm on psychedelics laying
down is a whole nother world different
situations love it
but but like stoned
i'm i'm way less stoned sitting down
standing up
but yeah i saw that we just told me was
bad like stand up yeah you gotta stand
up when you're smoking stupid you stump
me i gave you i give you stand up wait
now sit down
oh stop yelling oh i'm so glad i'm not a
piece of [ __ ] you do you want to burn
like that when i was a kid
that was so good i have good karma the
dude who first started selling me weed
billy oh you remember him yeah billy
something yeah he just
he
yeah he he what jacob he convinced me
that the seeds were the way to go
what are you talking about because he
was like i was like hey man there's more
seeds this week
and he was like yep oh when you started
yeah he was like yeah dude you get to
i'm saving them for you you get to plant
them
these are seeds dude these are weed
seeds pretty soon you won't need me
oh yeah that's good oh that's good yo
man i was washing dishes at 15 years old
in a kitchen
and that seemed like i was like well
always make sure you leave just enough
so i can roll a joint he was like oh
okay
and then he would just seat it up
and then i remember i had like this draw
full of seeds and i showed my also i
showed adam
i was like hey [ __ ]
and he was like
what
i was like a [ __ ]
dude's been selling me seeds and he's
like
you're so stupid
that's not how that works
and he was like definitely but then he
said he goes what was your plan where
are we gonna you're just gonna plant
them in mom's garden like where were you
gonna grow your weed you dum-dum yeah
you throw it anywhere on your walk to
school that's what i did when i was a
kid
that i could periodically look at i did
it in oregon once
how did that go i [ __ ] moved away and
forgot about them
i hope they're huge that would be
amazing
was it on somebody's land this is the
park but the park is a forest
what the park's like hello trees in
portland oh so easy right in front of a
mountain so you
went into the forest marks your spot
yeah it's a big tree uh lined up with
that guy's house way out there that's
what i did yeah you would have never
found that spot never never no of course
not i thought i was all cool yeah some
child shank [ __ ] hey or some dwight walk
do you hear the bees andy duvane duvein
uh andy two freight good friends
uh that's a good [ __ ] movie
yeah yeah it's about time all-time
favorite movie josh i don't know if i
can give you that okay all time not
what's your favorite two comedies you
could watch all the time
[Music]
um
why can't i remember the name of that
talladega knights ricky bobby that's
what i would put up there for me [ __ ]
dude
um
that's a great one too this is the end
oh it's such a good one that was a good
[ __ ] movie yeah it's funny
so most comedies aren't funny that third
act and it was funny the entire it was a
good movie the entire time funny yeah it
was never not funny and it got more
ridiculous
in anything with danny mcbride and james
franco
that whole riff about jerking off on
each other that's good yeah anime brow
is just a funny [ __ ] person tropic
thunder yo okay my cousin william that's
one of his favorite movies he tells me
watch it with the commentary on
because robert downey jr stays in
character through the entire [ __ ] dvd
commentary
and apparently ben stiller shows up late
and they do not let him [ __ ] forget
about it for the whole two-hour movie of
commentary i still have yet to do it i'm
gonna have to do that i have yet to do
it my cousin william tells me like you
haven't watched the commentary because
remember he goes i don't [ __ ] drop my
i don't break character the dvd release
remember he said yeah yeah
so he stays in character to the [ __ ]
commentary jesus yeah apple's hilarious
that's hilarious i took it i remember i
took you
to that we sat right up
right up close i think to this grade yep
yo that opening those three movie fake
movie trailers
oh that was some good [ __ ] [ __ ] good
night yeah that was good that was like
opening of that come on there are so
many funny
but i don't
think you could do that movie today no
we'll get you butt hurt about it
there's so many things you couldn't do
you couldn't do a lot of that simple
simple jack simple jock you couldn't do
simple jack you could do rob all of
robert downey jr's character that's
right his entire character your simple
jack
yeah you couldn't do
you couldn't do simple jack you couldn't
do robert downey jr i say robert jody jr
i would vote for that all day
more you can't was funny you can't do
you couldn't do that he also did asian
in that movie which you can't do
but you know why it was funny it's
because his character was breaking away
from the movie oh i get it you know like
i get it i think that's why people get
so upset like it's the dumb guy's
character in the movie yeah playing an
actor it was like
but that movie was so [ __ ] funny
holy [ __ ] that's a good [ __ ] movie
man uh
look at those two you know and if you're
talking about old school like me growing
up go fletch
i've never seen fletch yeah
i'm even not even sure it would hold up
no
it's sad when movies don't hold up yeah
i've watched some movies recently oh
yeah i think for me like if two comedies
growing up would probably be
fletch
i don't know i loved major league
it's a good one i loved it that's a good
one and i it wasn't
because it was the funniest movie
i mean would you come back to the future
comedy
no
i mean not like it it's only that
account right no it's like an action
uh i would say it's like a
comedic actually a comedy because all
the [ __ ] they were going i would go
action comedy maybe
but i don't know because sports movies i
guess it'd be action i i don't know if
it would be it will also handle the
action of them traveling through [ __ ]
time
with all that [ __ ] but like so i i i
what comes first time travel or
teleportation
as a question yeah like just like this
is where we're changing the subject
right now like that's no [ __ ] idea
we're just changing the subject now i
just wanted to make sure that's what i
was focusing on we were good and then i
was good in that spot look at that face
that happened
he's hot man i just i just wanted to
make sure i was like i just held josh's
head up
it bounced it back up
so what's there were
it
i hope teleportation that's the one
superpower i would have if i could have
it really yeah
teleportation yeah i just want to fly
and not be able to get shot
because [ __ ] would shoot at
your ass flying over there yeah but
teleporting for
just like if i could just go anywhere
great i would love that
yeah that was a crazy subject
teleportation
huh
what a subject change
yeah my my brain just no i love it all
right so teleportation you
what was the questions
i think you said which comes first time
travel or teleportation
and
and then i said teleportation but that's
the one superpower i would have oh i and
then what's the what you're trying to
figure out what the superpower i think
teleportation comes before time travel
i think that i think it's happening
right now
no i don't but i wish it did what if i
just [ __ ] boom disappeared
what the [ __ ] yeah that would be amazing
we come through the door 40 years old
like no
dude go back
reverse it
yeah i found the best drugs in the
future
yo
you're like that's just i just really
imaginable
that i got to tell you i'm pretty high
i think
yo i think
teleportation happens in some kind of
form or fashion
in the next
50 years i'll be dead yeah i think so i
think it'll be soon i'll be alive
yeah thanks for rubbing that in
you ain't enjoying all the benefits yeah
you pointed out that you were gonna be
dead
you didn't have to point out that you
were gonna be alive
i mean
i felt like it was necessary
of us has to enjoy it yeah
hold on enjoy teleportation that's gonna
be the last thing i say to you
we're gonna be
we're gonna
we're gonna be in the hospital and i'm
gonna be like joy teleportation yes is
it
i love you
i just want you to know
you bought that [ __ ] porn
i hope you enjoy teleportation
and i know it was you
that bought the porn
yo can you guys do a skit with makeup
artists and [ __ ]
this is the best version of click i've
ever seen
dude can i tell you we were always in
class
i was in click with jacob and his sister
and his brother right you were in click
the movie
we were watching the movie we weren't oh
you were watching him okay we're in the
movie i got you we're watching it
and uh there was some there was a heavy
scene in there yeah where the rain
sitting in the face and adam sanders
died like the there's some heavy
father-son stuff in there right and so
and and as i had had sons and also a dad
but having sons now it really hit me in
a different way so there was a scene i
don't remember what the scene was but i
remember i was
i was tearing up a little bit you know
my oldest son i guess he was probably
he had to be 10 or something like that
at 11.
he just goes hey
angry yeah
you guys are you crying
i said yeah a little bit
he said he looked at he looks at jacob
and his sister we were younger than him
he goes
looks at me and he goes
get it together
[Laughter]
and i was like damn it yeah
[Laughter]
crying in front of them get your [ __ ]
together yeah that's [ __ ] incredible
that's so funny ah that's the best
[ __ ] thing i've ever heard
get it together
holy [ __ ] like you're a pit like you're
a [ __ ] pitcher yeah
man you gotta
you know you need to do but you need to
get it together yo that's [ __ ]
incredible
love it
dude it's amazing sorry another subject
change are you ready for this thing i
saw and i want you guys opinion because
it blew my [ __ ] mind i still have
this
wait what time is it i don't [ __ ]
know 9 33
how long have we been doing this
241
235 all right
he's looking for your reaction i'm not
telling you no you know i'm driving
yeah but it's the first time you've ever
in your life said out loud you may have
said it in your head do you need to do
that
it's the first time you've ever said it
i was like i'm not mad at you it's not
the first time i've said that to you
yeah for sure
i don't know about it
when would have been another time
another i don't know sorry for giving
your dad drinks wait you might have said
that once before
yeah but but did i
bet i didn't take it no you didn't
listen so you took it
this doesn't have a good ending this
isn't a [ __ ] happy ending on that one
i mean it is for you but not in the
sense of listening to your son
well the best part is i feel honestly
i feel like oh
he's so
um
oh [ __ ] i know he's gonna get me exactly
where i need to go he's a good driver
good driver and just you know safe and
he's my buddy man yeah i'm just keeping
it straight because i'm gonna make sure
he's
good goofy ass gets
i gotta be honest
it's really funny thinking about this
gave your dad drugs i'm sorry you
shouldn't do all those drugs
yo my [ __ ] head kind of hurts from
laughing oh my god that hasn't happened
in a very long time
yo i closed my eyes for a while and i
looked up yeah these mushrooms hit me a
little
i definitely feel uh i wasn't even
talking to the mic my bad stand up
maybe you should stand up
is that like a ludacris stand up i'll do
it if it's a ludicrous stand up hold on
let's see let's see if you're higher
i definitely felt a little more wobbly
yeah you get a little bit of the ball
so that's why you stand up yeah
that's the whole point of it all right
we also have marty's been standing there
and marty's been moving this thing yeah
listen you know what something oh [ __ ]
yeah oh what the [ __ ] happened right now
yeah so you get a little higher because
you're
don't you
are you looking genius are you a little
higher i just felt like they hit me a
little harder yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think it's because your blood your your
heart marty jump in here
nobody can bail you out of that one no i
think your heart
your
i think your heart rate or something
your heart goes faster which moves the
things in through your body more i wish
we had overlay so you could put this
over josh like the more you know
right over it
yeah hey do you have that on the
soundboard that'd be sick you guys oh
that'd be amazing
you guys
zero
zero bars zero i liked your guys's uh
it's a no for me dawg it's all right
[Laughter]
you guys are the thing where you talked
about
modern slang and then you try to
interpret it that was fun
he taught me what a
grizzly was no no a glizzy oh he said
grizzly like the bear
[Music]
yeah i gotta help him out
there's no r there's no r in there so he
told me where the glizzy was
is that what you said yeah that's okay
yeah it just laughed at him
it was just spitting his water out okay
so he sucked he told me
that but what else did he tell me
i had to guess what did i have to guess
yeah i would give you the word you would
have to get yeah that's what i watched
this [ __ ] was [ __ ] hilarious do that
more what what what were some other
terms that you taught me um bet
huh like bet
did you teach me bet i think that's from
my era
it's a it's a very it's an old school
word for sure but [ __ ] use it
heavy now they do very heavy now
yeah you have never used it before i
used it tonight dude after you've been
hearing me sit you did you said to me
out loud did you just say bet yeah you
know why you said it because i'm
constantly saying it and i text it to
you all the time so you were like oh
yeah i'll just throw that in here and
see if he notices
that's mission accomplished
come on
come on
i know that move
but it's definitely because i say it a
bunch
i'll bet
was that close
not really
did i do it right
did i did i did i do that oh no oh
[ __ ] man this [ __ ] hurts dude did you do
you ever remember
um smoking yourself deaf a little bit um
one time i ate so many edibles hash
edibles
that i couldn't hear anything but louder
you know yeah or like 30 seconds yeah
it's a tough one that's scary and the
voice sounds all voices sound very
charlie brown yeah
you don't know if you want to like let
anybody know yeah because
because they're going to be like how
high are you and you're going to be like
really high
yeah you're just some of the highest
i've ever been in my life i smoked
myself deaf that's how high i am i've
been
actually it's all the other animals
though that bad
i i actually it only happened to me the
only times it ever happened to me i was
young young
oh this this happened like four years
ago five years ago oh no [ __ ] oh yeah it
was not fun did you ever take that
edible again
my friend's a dummy
and he was just putting shatter inside
of his sauce and putting it right on the
burgers
so we're going to town and i ate a lot
and a lot more i did a story i fell on a
woman
like where in my booth i was at a booth
running a booth like this
almost nearly [ __ ] my pants wait
wait wait
wait i missed a beat running what booth
my my booth at a high times cup oh okay
i was running a booth yeah and i was
[ __ ] up
and then i fell on a lady
multiple times
okay she's running the booth next to me
she's sitting in a chair oh i trip you
know there's no walls i trip i land on
her
so i'm so sorry i'm sorry
the second time i land on this woman
this is like she's in the back of the
booth and someone leaves some bags in
the way and i trip you know just random
but i'm [ __ ] high spinning like
not fun
i trip and i go oh
elbow full force and i turn around like
get
the [ __ ] out of here she's out of her
chair
did you knock her out of her out of her
[ __ ] chair i'm not even done
third and final time i landed on this
lady same lady same person
over the course of eight hours let me
ask you a question third time boner or
no
[ __ ] no
see all the whole time
this was my this was my uh joke this
whole time i did it on purpose yeah
i'm just kidding the third time i landed
full body force i just passed out
i like [ __ ] got dizzy bam and i saw
it was her like there's no way in the
world i'm not getting killed after this
this is insane it was genuinely
none of it on purpose
but the thing is i was so [ __ ] up
let's see what happens
i put my body weight on her to get off
of her because i was so like
so i put like my arm on her to get up
she she went in she was so [ __ ]
pissed i thought she was gonna start
hitting me i would have let her i felt
so bad yeah dude listen by the way
it was bad second time
i'm mad first time you know yeah the
thing is all first times it was their
bags in my booth on the floor
where i'm running back and forth getting
stuff and i went oh and i landed on her
the first time oh her bags yeah i'm like
yo can you get you guys bags out of my
[ __ ] booth i got her chocolate went
into your peanut butter
yeah and her peanut butter got into my
[ __ ] job that's right and then i
elbow dropped him yeah and then that's
why i karate chopped her in the [ __ ]
face yes dude
my life's seinfeld right now marty knows
the story at the end hour later i'm
cleaning up i'm walking to my car
putting my stuff away and i see a guy
that i know that runs a company
he's like yo i'm gonna go get you some
stuff
uh i wasn't here all day i had people
running my booth
he walks up two minutes later
with his wife i haven't met
it's the [ __ ] i landed on three times
no [ __ ] way guys rosie's staring at
me i just look at it she's like that
looking at me i'm like get i'm glad
you're here
so you can back me up that this is real
seinfeld moment she looked at me he
introduced me to her
she played it cool and she was i mean
she was screaming at me just an hour i
mean going in
calling me everything and i just took it
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i was just so
dizzy
the third time i passed out i just like
opened my eyes i was on top of this lady
elbow all
so she shook my hand like oh nice to
meet you and she didn't say [ __ ] they
walked away and never seen this man
again
no do you know how bad i felt bumping
into somebody at a concert three times
what the [ __ ]
i landed full body weight
on her on her fold-up chair
so that was the highest i've ever been
when you asked earlier
that's when i went deaf that day
and i like three or four hours don't i
don't recall anything i just saw
pictures of me the next day like what
i took a picture with you oh my god
were you realizing in in real time how
ridiculous it was
no because i was so violently [ __ ] up
that i didn't want to be that high
anymore because my friend told me don't
eat those ones just because he's like i
feel like i'm about to start peeking on
shrooms right now i'm like
you're a [ __ ] i was talking [ __ ] and
then i told rosie are these cause they
had shroom tinctures in burgers too i'm
like did you guys give me [ __ ]
mushrooms because i'm dizzy i can't
[ __ ] hear oh but you know what i mean
i'm running a booth and my teeth hurt
i told you my teeth felt like they were
gonna fall out of my [ __ ] face
it's like there was so much pressure
it was the weirdest feeling i ever felt
and that happened to be on cbd pills oh
on cbd pills this guy makes cbd pills
make it was like eight years ago and it
felt like my teeth like when you smashed
your toe
i felt like my teeth and my gums oh dude
i hate that feeling that throbbing
feeling oh that's how it felt anyway
that was the highest i've ever been
the high like and how for how long was
that i [ __ ] met eight hours but i
probably ate like six thousand
milligrams and it was a lot unregulated
no this is pre
legal companies yeah so [ __ ]
were going hard
um
hey how would you feel if i went pee
on me or like right here how would i
feel about it yeah what if i get up you
know we could do we would just go like
this
beep
that was
nice
can you get back in the chair can i get
back in the chair yeah
what kind of question is that should
make sure
can you get back in the chair i left the
truck
well
apparently so
i'm going to tell you a little secret
ready all right
ready
go
never blown my nose in my life
that sounds preposterous and tell me how
that's what i said by the way i just
have never blown my i've never bloom i
don't think i would like it
i don't know if this is a known thing
you know about i i just heard him i
heard him say it to me today actually
for the first time but now that i think
back on it like they've never seen me
blow my nose you're so lucky you don't
have no no no no
he definitely does
what sometimes he'll get sick but he'll
never he'll never blow his nose he'll
just like stick something up there and
just like feel like he clears it out
yeah yeah clear it out with a good
mm-hmm you never wit
no i don't think i'd like it
it sounds really yucky
did you just realize this or have you
been no aware of this your whole life
that i've never blown my nose oh i knew
i've known
yeah i'm aware that that's not something
that i do you don't want boogers all
over your mouth and your lips that's the
part that i really don't like you know
what's funny is i was telling jacob
today
look man you know
what's what really i think turned me off
to nose blowing in general was my
grandfather because he used to carry a
handkerchief
and that's the grossest thing
like
they used to blow their
nose
and put it back in their pocket
and then just
blow their nose again
and put it back in their pocket and then
if you're in news if your nose blew
they would just take their handkerchief
out and rub your face that's horrible
what are we doing like
and and they would just you know what
i'm saying like how many times are we
going back to that handkerchief it's a
one-time and then why are we putting it
back why are you putting it back in your
pocket
what i don't get is what the [ __ ] is
happening how do have you never had to
blow your nose your nose doesn't run
yeah i used some clean exercises yeah
you just got real [ __ ] cool there
let's do some cleaners
would you do it right now for the first
time kleenex
would you blow yourself
i'll do some cleanness right now i got
nothing in my nose to blow
perfect and you can do it and knock it's
not all over your lips
did i do it
did i do it
that by the way that's called breathing
oh i've been doing that for a long time
you're good at it nailed it well done
yeah
we call that manual breathing yeah yeah
yeah
ooh mb
i'm good at that
all right and non-manual what's not
manual call automatic that's the one
thank you
i just went over this the other day with
a car
no that's right
that was today
no thomas
remember you're like oh [ __ ] i just had
to switch to manual breathing there for
a second oh so [ __ ] up the other day
when i was taking a giant dab with
oh god i gotta breathe for myself for a
minute jesus christ wow that's no
because i was just because i was so yeah
yeah it was a facetime i think by the
way that's
maybe
another reason why i wouldn't dab i i
don't take the normal sized person's dab
and or the same [ __ ] this man you could
take a little dab you could take i don't
take gloves anymore but you could you
could be cool with dead yeah i do like
the word glob
yeah they taste like they like smash
things on the [ __ ] leg they smash
we like stone cold
and [ __ ] take out when i met thomas
yeah it was like a [ __ ] menorah and
they were just like smashing down works
what was that the word yeah eminor
that's right i did
what
did you ever see my menorah bong
do you remember the menorah bomb oh i
definitely remember the menorah
the menorah bong has awesome oh dude it
was i used it when you were out of town
you think i was just gonna let that
beauty sit in your cabinet and do
nothing because you weren't ever gonna
use it locked
this cabinet is locked
it wasn't a single locked [ __ ]
cabinet on you yeah we didn't like
anything it's all good because you but
your mom wouldn't let me lock anything
up
what she wouldn't like the way it looked
oh gotcha
it'd be weird yeah and like this is a
key lock and it just blends in with the
[ __ ] like normal house like a normal
yeah like a normal kilo what do you mean
on the door you know the doors yeah yeah
i don't know why we didn't have locks on
doors
yeah none of what well we had one lock
on a door and the door locked from the
outside so that was so funny so people
would lock you in your room
yeah yeah
but but i figured out i figured out
about two weeks in
that with my nail or with a coin i could
turn yeah and just walk out but that was
weird the only lock on that door in that
house was on the outside of your door
you eventually had a lock
on our door we had to put on your door
yeah
but we didn't want you guys to have
blocks on your doors
we wanted you to know that we weren't
coming at any time but we could
i could [ __ ] cramer slide into your
room
you guys got into a phase though and you
just didn't even like knock and like let
me answer you knocked as you opened the
door and i was like hey man what the
it's a very parental thing what the [ __ ]
hey
hey just letting you know
that's your move too my creamery and all
the [ __ ] time
the worst thing possible if you got that
[ __ ] door locked hey if the door is
locked and it's quiet in there shit's
going down
there is some [ __ ] if there's the door's
locked and it's quiet
you're not going to see what's going on
in there oh my god yeah it is
it's going there there you go they're
going downtown to clown town
hero said
that is awful yeah
awful barty you're rolling joints now
man that's like the eighth joint i've
seen your world today yeah you're on
yeah
i'm saying because you've been on it one
time yeah you've been inspired me i like
rolling jordan
yeah different josh josh kesselman yeah
but this josh should try and roll some
joints here i can't really enjoy this i
can teach you about 10 minutes i i think
you i think he also could teach you yeah
maybe i i don't think i could learn
anything right now
no not that i don't even want to [ __ ]
teach right now what could you learn
right now if i was like here i would
like to teach you something and you
would be like this is a fact
yeah if i can retain a fact right okay
hold on let me see let me see if i can
find one
okay i got one oh okay
um
do you want to know the reasons why
sloths are move as slow as they do
[Music]
go let me let me guess let me guess oh i
guess there's two reasons okay yeah okay
why do you even know this is astonishing
i watched a lot of animal planets excuse
me why do sloths move super slowly yes
one because they can't move that fast
physical capabilities yeah physical
thank you very much marty thank you take
it away
[Laughter]
huh
maybe because
they they
it can't exert that much energy maybe it
has something to do with how much they
eat
not how much they eat what they eat what
they eat and so it's very low carb
no what are they you're thinking you're
thinking the wrong way
it's high carb no no it's not
[Laughter]
that's the right if you say low carb
that's the wrong way the other way is
high carb no no no it doesn't deal with
anything carbs it has to deal with like
specifically what they eat gluten free
no i mean
i mean i guess technically sure what i
got what's going on wait wait i gotta
ask someone else
this is the last question i want to ask
and this is real
what are we talking about right now
he said he give me a fact
yeah he said give him a fact
and you said all right let me think
about that and i said i have one about
why sloths move as slow as they only one
oh that's right that's right that's
right the table
okay
so why do sloths move that slowly well
so what they eat is a bunch is
eucalyptus so the eucalyptus is like hot
did you kill me
you heard me
and so eugene swear your mother
no not today
[Laughter]
that's just a joke um the eucalyptus is
high in a substance that uh acts as like
what thc acts like in humans so it's
really high so they're just really high
all the time until they move so slow get
the [ __ ] out no i swear to god same
thing with clubbers that's why they they
eat a lot of eucalyptus
it's like it keeps them in a state of
like 80 of their life they're just
stoned all the time amazing also but
which one of them has chlamydia
probably both of them no they're koalas
i remember crazy yeah dude what a weird
what a weird well-known fact about a
wild animal we do animal planet
voiceovers we're doing an all right job
right now i think so we're doing an okay
give me an animal i'll give you a voice
oh jesus
we've officially hit that stage
you know how good i am at voices ostrich
the worst how good i am the worst
the absolute
drawing or ostrich oh
ostrich at the bank he gave you
oh i'd like to make a departure
what was that
i think it would be higher
[Music]
yeah that's the sloth i feel like the
ostrich would be a little more high
pitched sounded like the jungle book
vultures at the end the dumb one i don't
know what do you want to do yeah
i don't know
what give me a british accent
are you ready for mine that's here okay
give me a sentence what do you want me
to say
um not give me a topic give me your
british text no i don't want your accent
i want your
give me the sentence
in american and i'll say it in british
go
um
hey love would you like some tea no no
don't don't give me any help no that's
how is that oh you just like give you
random just like random things ostrich
went to the bank and asked for an
encyclopedia by the way a sentence i can
remember [ __ ] i'm pretty happy
what did you say
how many words
[ __ ]
was that 74 words
did you did you make sure you included
every letter in the alphabet in that
sentence
[Applause]
an ostrich
an ostrich walks into a bank
try that
okay for what
you say give you a sentence of random
words oh that is indeed a random set of
words for you to try with a british eye
here we go right
[Laughter]
[Music]
so bad
jesus christ
do you want to repeat the sentence
yeah you better
just wanted to check that check's out
right that checks
an ostrich walks into a bank
an ostrich walks into a bank
honestly
i mean for worse i mean it could have
been definitely like really
like uh
what's the [ __ ] from like
snatch and lockstar oh the [ __ ] um
that's how you sounded like a scary
british guy yeah well i know why you can
do that do you want to tell them why you
know how to do that
oh because that
audition oh my gosh that's why you
always every time you go to a british
accent you kind of sound like a terrible
jack sparrow
do you remember tell him what i did to
you guys in the van he would bought like
a four but
i got an audition tell him uh yeah you
did get in
if was i right about the movie it was
for epic epic remember the movie epic
movie that came out
it was one of those spoof movies and it
is yes about all the movies blended
together yeah and it was okay and so
there was a role for spoof jack sparrow
and i
played a cockney tape i'm terrible at
access
[Music]
so i went
to when samuel french was still a place
in la and i went and bought a cd
that taught me cockney
but when did i play it
every time we got in the car oh [ __ ]
and it was nothing but that my sister
was like it's cool i'm learning too and
i'm like caitlin shut up
dude
shut up did you remember any of the
do you remember any of the lyrics from
the there were songs no it was just like
a script that you would go over
from the beginning every time yeah and
it was like a four minute i uh
i heard two who's on the roof of the
room you know one of those things
it would play over and over my daughter
and i would look at each other and we'd
say it to each other we uh
and from the back seat you'd hear him go
turn it off
hated that [ __ ]
so this is another way you [ __ ] with him
that was
but i was also trying to learn something
yeah and also in his defense he did have
an audition for the movie so yeah that
was terrible at access and there was no
other place he could do it in a lot of
time he spent in the car driving us
around yeah because you know who didn't
want me to do at the house beth she was
like you know what if it's between me
being tortured in them
that's
can't be the kids
you've always got a pixie you're on
saturday
which is fair
but it wasn't worth mine
it was so good
it turned out right yeah it was so funny
i really was funny
how much
do you know when something's not a big
deal
but then
somehow it shifts gears and then you're
like when did this become a big deal
it became
such a big deal
to you
that
your sister before you would get in the
car she'd be like
we're playing the tape right and i'd be
like oh yeah we're playing the tape
it's really good that's really funny i'm
like yeah it drives him crazy
he's still like
hate that but i was trying to get he
dude listen how many times did i listen
to that pokemon cd
hey you know what how many times did i
listen to that also one thing he says
that he knows he says it wrong and just
tries to get a jump out of me
the pokemon pissed you got when he said
that that pokey man the pokey
i just sat there and ate it just out
there
he knew too yeah
but he's so smart and he doesn't fall
for that [ __ ] anymore but you know i'll
tell you something now man like this is
my favorite
traveling with him
has changed
has made me like to travel again
like did this whole
part of our lives
where we're spending more adult time
together is like
crazy
crazy for me
like crazy crazy most people don't get
to do it you know and like
genuinely i just like hanging out
with them
absolutely makes it super easy yeah
stop yeah it is pretty
and i pay and i and that pay i mean yeah
i used to do it for free anyways
i kind of graduated to making some money
yeah and he's like your bodyguard your
wellness officer he does that
i'll just go through everything and just
find everything i'm like you missed a
lot of things
he really like yeah
in a lot of ways
he's
besides he's not booking it and all that
stuff but he does a lot of stuff a road
manager would do which is why i pay him
you could [ __ ] believe it or not
i don't have my [ __ ] together
so
you mean you don't personally coordinate
with all the comedy clubs and book all
your dates yourself
yeah it's a shocker right
are you shocked by it
i've worked you're giving you i'm still
shocked by the show yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so like
you know
he
also
[Music]
even when he's high
he
he can keep [ __ ] together
like he really like
he's like he's just
an adult a logical adult yeah you're
doing new you're trying to say he's more
he's mature more mature
i don't know if he's more i wouldn't
call it more mature i picked my moments
yeah man you're right right time right
place
like i think you're a sniper
i think you're a sniper
i like that i like your spots
i like and kill people yeah you snipe
your jokes you sniped a couple in here
tonight dude yeah you're a sniper zerg a
couple couple one liners couple a couple
shots from the hills you know what i'm
saying yo those reaction videos you did
[Music]
are so funny
that was good let's hear that one
oh do it again do it again
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he genuinely loved it when he closed his
eyes and he did that i was like please
marty for the love of god play something
really [ __ ] loud i need him to think
it's something and not be that you know
you know
you know how he likes to scare me
loud noises [ __ ] the car horn oh when
i when i go the car horn scared you know
why carhart's so scary
death
don't get killed yeah you're about to
die i have a video of you uh when we
drove you cross country to nashville and
i was in that giant truck i have a video
of you and mom at the door and me
pulling on the wire and just going
and you're just going ah
just like getting a little quick jump
it's pretty great he
knows how easily i scare jazz heads yeah
call back so so we started with
he definitely takes advantage of it the
car he's like the car horn's easy i
don't have to do anything it's like when
i'm dropping him off somewhere and not
when he's getting out of your car that's
all your car alarm okay when i was
17 or 17 or 18 my very first car was a
was a 2004 kia rio
if you know this anything anyone
listening if you know what this car
looks like it's a literal tin can on
wheels like i got in a very slight
fender bender with like a truck that had
a hitch on the back my whole my whole
hood was like completely dented in it
had engine problems after that and i was
like
and you were fine yesterday like what's
the deal
um and
the one weird thing about it is it had
the loudest
lock and unlock sound and it sounded
like
tweety like a tweety bird so i named him
tweety and that's just what he was and i
could and the range on the keys
you know it could be on my street up
like we lived on a property that had two
two houses on it but we lived at the
back property and that front there was a
front property occupied by somebody else
and from my window i could roll my
window down or like
roll my window up in my room and listen
outside i could lock and unlock my car
from my bedroom window like it was
range was ridiculous so we used to walk
the dog together
and i would bring my keys with me
just
just for the sake of it
and
every time like just on the comeback and
then we coming back and it's like we're
just about to go inside
on our street
next driveway's up and i just reached my
head into my pocket and i hit the lock
button
and it just scared me
because it's purely silent and then
there's just this loud
car horn
and it's just like oh my [ __ ] god i
remember one time
i said
out loud
i go hey man
the camera is not gonna [ __ ] work
this time and he beeped it and it scared
me anyway
and i was like son of a [ __ ] it's just
it's so good yeah yeah that was that was
pretty funny it's just yeah i scare
pretty easily
you that's the episodes i scare pretty
easily
now i'm not sure if you can tell that
i've smoked any marijuana
party
don't do that you know how many people
you scared in their room right now
i don't think you understand what you
just did to a lot of people that's my
very favorite folks oh
nope don't like that one damn are you
just
that was scary in the [ __ ] voice
marty was
staring at me we got new sound effects
this is a safe zone no more
you're fine
you're fine what do we have we had three
we're wearing the [ __ ] faster yeah what
do we have three three minutes how long
have we been here what are we succeeded
316
stone cold perfect let's do this
guys
let's end this hey when are we starting
the podcast
i'm starting to get some [ __ ]
when you feel a little bit sick when the
mushrooms get you i started to feel a
little bit so you know what
oh god
that reminds me
i think i'm gonna want some food
yeah look
that's how i feel somebody put some
cookies
what cookies i mean you can always
always order doordash
but then you'd have to go down and get
it actually no you can type in the room
number and they'll drop it at your door
we'll get there
we'll get there we'll get you there oh
my god all right let's oh no
i can feel it
i can feel it
so where can everybody fall
so where can everybody fight
yo josh
it passed
there it goes
every time oh these are about to hit me
holy
whoa
i always feel sick right before they hit
me oh no
where can you find tickets to your show
sorry are you about to be super high um
no
no more these weren't ideas can i ask
you a question go what show you talking
about
any shows you do oh yeah right yeah hey
hey hey you do comedy for a living yeah
so it's at joshuacomedy.com
comedianjoshwolf.com hey everybody you
know john joshua.com uh jacob will be
with me in san diego this weekend oh
this weekend oh [ __ ] what's the date
this weekend no what's the date
april 1st and 2nd thank you oh the whole
week oh okay cool
yeah it's a friday saturday no show
sunday right correct
it's just show sunday it's friday
saturday sunday that's why i can't go
to your mom's wow my wife's getting
honored
uh it doesn't matter
that's that's not what he meant that's
not what he meant my wife um my wife's
get i was going to tell you a story
about why i know i have a sunday night
show but doesn't matter it my wife's
getting honored and it's amazing she's
an amazing filmmaker but
you don't want to hear the whole [ __ ]
story
that's why i said it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter to you
oh my god right yeah no i just said yeah
yeah just just keep talking just to
waste should i keep that
here's what i really mean
no no no i was kidding now listen right
into the camera get people who aren't
married yet this is what you're supposed
to do keep talking about it because that
way it's always going to be better
no don't do that just say as few words
as possible
oh my god so it's comedian josh wolfe
comedian joshua
for tour dates and tickets
and
hey man and we do a podcast called hey
man with three a's where can you find
that uh on all
platforms where you can listen to
podcasts yeah and there's a youtube
channel hey man youtube channel if you
want to watch all of them hey man so hey
m a a a n three a's correct yeah h e y m
a a a there might be an x explanation
there's not an exclamation mark
we'll drop a link in the description for
everyone out there that wants to check
any of this out the link is in the
description of youtube if you're on
spotify the link's in the description
there too
whoa
i'm trying to keep it together a little
bit i felt a little spacey for a minute
yeah i i mean
i think i definitely am high
for sure yeah you held yourself up on
the microphone earlier yeah i think when
you know it's in there
and i definitely
[Music]
zoned out only three times so i'm
excited to see how that looks on camera
where i was like and i'm back and people
are still talking cool
i know the feeling
where you're like in people the
conversation nobody's staring at me god
it's back here
with people surrounded
snuck right in back in the groove landed
the plane nobody was looking yeah
so i wonder
if there'll be a shot of me just like
this i hope there was a time where he
was doing that i looked at you
you were doing that
yeah
[ __ ] yeah but listen okay
i'm right as rain now
all right so ready you never heard that
saying right has rain never heard that
no comedian joshua.com for tour dates
san diego
um sacramento
uh st louis austin texas nashville
tennessee
baltimore maryland all right so we can
just check that on the website or you
could just go to the community just
remember all of that that was comedian
that's my job dude that's my job dude 40
seconds ago [ __ ] that job i was high but
i'm back yeah but did this are you going
to be talking about my job it's time to
sober the [ __ ] up we're good
i i feel very i feel like it got me
brighter like i feel a little more alert
they hit me a little bit more but not in
a bad way that's that's stand up
now the sickness once it passes i'm
they're i'm good but it just like it
hits me for a minute
well those are fun they weren't too
strong no not at all and they're not
they're nice and they're chill yeah
yeah i'm gonna enjoy watching you we're
not doing any anything all right we just
took some
supplement and drank some yeah
all right thank you guys so much for
being here we've been here for over
three hours jesus christ
thank you let's just say the godfather
episode
one hell of an episode honestly you'll
remember much of what we talked about i
was just [ __ ] up the whole time did we
marty is
oh it's not that camera's not on oh is
that one yeah are we still on
hey
marty
what are you doing
i think it's just a battery change oh
all right well hey listen
thanks for your input
[Music]
yeah thanks for taking him out of some
ditches yeah yeah i really appreciate it
appreciate it thank you for that you
should do a segment on here just call
marty take it away
i like that
i just started throwing marty toppings
yeah that's something to say they're
right take it away
oh i love that i'm not going to tell you
what i'm going to talk about either
horrible [ __ ]
yeah marty you got it
yeah marty you got it from here take it
away oh i like that marty take it away
oh man do you have like a news station
like a like a breaking news sound
baby is that too old i got a cricket
that's like telling that's mountain [ __ ]
yeah
what would be breaking news
yeah breaking news type of [ __ ] i think
i mean what's your breaking news sound
oh
yes
i mean you're [ __ ] making people's
nights in their room the worst
dude leave that on marty guys for real
one tear just came out of my butthole
that's how scary
i saw the whole yeah that was like i
stood up i shook down i shook to the
side i did the whole hokey pokey in like
under half a sec
[Laughter]
damn that was like a [ __ ]
all right
oh here we go holy [ __ ] guys thank you
both for being here thank you so much
for having us this is one of the few
times you've ever had two guests on it
once and this is fun this was great
thank you guys i wanna i wanna uh
when you in in town i want to do you
guys a show also so whenever you guys
have time that would be fun that would
be amazing actually that would be
absolutely yeah you could be
a very first guest
oh
[ __ ] okay
it was for us i didn't oh yeah you were
our first guest
that's right
you were the second episode
we did a solo the first and you were the
first guest i forgot about that
wow
that was in the other room yeah
that's in the other room
good [ __ ]
well anyway we'll figure it out but you
can watch it hey man everything's linked
in the descriptions
and communityjoshwaltz.com we talked
about it like i know but i'm back on it
we got it
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for being a designated driver always
have a designated driver always
be safe and that's one to grow on
the more you know
need that sound
yeah yeah yeah
all right marty thank you so much for
sitting through this thank you my
[ __ ] face i know my forehead [ __ ]
hurts from laughing dude yeah but i
haven't eaten food in like eight hours
so maybe that's why the mushrooms got me
a little but this was fun thank you for
being that was terrifying that's there
that's what i know you're right
[Laughter]
oh
oh that's so true
i can feel it i was like why is my feels
like my face isn't working for a second
[Applause]
once again let's end this kid
all right he's crying i'm crying that's
the perfect time to end it
all right
thanks guys thank you
appreciate it appreciate it yeah for
everyone out there this has been the
dopey usual podcast have a dope ass day
are you [ __ ] kidding me
i hope you got that face
zoom in on that [ __ ] face
his whole brain person
i can feel it like what's happening
never done that that's crazy
[Music]
perfect